[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
yo yo
what's going on realm it is sunday
it is that day
the lord's
day
tell me how i'm sounding out here tell
me how it sounded what's going on look
at some shout outs right quick lydian
master what's going on
gerald mack i see you bro like you was
outside i love it the video and all that
that was really love so let's keep it
respectful you know what i'm saying
you're making a building oh gee
mass erect i can't say it like so off
what's going on christopher hart was
going on in there early antagonizing
people i see
shout out to kade six all right he's
back
it's aldrin you know
crow crows in the building derek ruther
what's up
you know what i mean corey mosley what's
going on hustle appreciate you thank you
yesterday hustle as well for me helping
out on the fly with my whole twitch you
can tell i was a new twitch streamer i
don't know what the hell i'm doing
it's a shout out absolutely it was
actually a user error i was uh
but i don't really use the xbox one
wireless headset as much that joint was
muted it was nothing to do with the
stream we had to do with the app so i
got it figured out god's hit man is in
the building doing it for the lord
putting them down for the laws god said
man
what's up here's ham solo i see you
arcade what's going on you already know
attic talk to the people right quick
what's going on guys
no doubt no doubt
[Music]
let's go dragon yobe what's up
oh powder yeah guys here so today's
powder y'all go to advanced gg.com
we got the new sour now of course cog is
a sour guy he likes that sour watermelon
we got to do salad we got the sour apple
you know what i'm saying go to vsg.com
put in discount code iron lord get that
new powder
[Music]
and we got the new new joint we got the
new joint we got um if y'all like that
game what is it split gate we got the
deal with split gate y'all remember on
ball pops from back in the day remember
ball pop son they got the split pop
rocket pop joint it tastes just like a
bomb pop from back in the day you know
what i'm saying so just make sure y'all
go get that i'm moving all type of
weight right there all type of weight we
got the split gate we got the sour we
got it all baby i got the best power i
got it for cheap cold iron lord wanna
check in make sure you do that
listen i gotta tell me for power i'm
sorry people you know what i said let's
go i'm moving away i'm doing it the
positive way y'all should salute me
anyway
we got a fun show
[Music]
man i got that way i got it for cheat
yeah red and white the blue popsicle
drink remember the red one yeah
it's literally
bomb pops from back in the day the
popsicle i got the split gate rocket pop
we got that new new man i'm telling
y'all it's lit go get that it's up on
the site right now move it all type of
way hey javier mckay what's up man maybe
we gonna get the ladies in the realm in
here it's gonna be a fun show king's all
pulling up all that you know what i mean
yo at oh sorry which one said your mic
sounds different
oh general max a little brother
you said your mics your audio sound like
you want a different mic that's what
hustle said
oh okay because of that now so he
finishing up his setup whatever but uh
we will be back
you know what i'm saying make sure y'all
focus up the ladies in the round will be
here and we'll have a good show today
i'll talk to y'all in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
key
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beating they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people on aim
[Music]
for them to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look
gotta mess up and turn me to an animal
and haters be swearing they real but
come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to starter regardless
of people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got
[Music]
you i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when
um
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger that's
who
let's do that again danny going down
over to the website go check it out
whether you're gonna get that focus for
the gaming session that energy a little
perk for the gym we're gonna get some
swag some merch maybe a ice shaker go
right on over there check out the
products but again really cool products
they don't hide behind any type of
proprietary blend
nonsense it's all transparent as far as
the ingredients the label green tea
caffeine kind of a healthy form of
natural caffeine none of that crash none
of that stuff so yeah again go check it
out you run in there you add it to your
cart use that referral link that we got
in the description and then you make
sure on the checkout you're putting in
iron lord again iron lord on the
checkout get yourself a nice discount
when you're checking out advanced gg and
like i said try the product for yourself
see what you think about it the lords we
love it and we are powered by advanced
gg so check that thing out
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be meto i know it's my
destiny work to cognito who cares if you
fly if you steal a mosquito you swear
you ain't something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it in nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
and we are live
welcome to the iron lord forecast llc
and also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 250 250 episodes y'all
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date i'm very excited about our special
guest and we've got the halo tv series
impressions
playstation spartacus inbound
marvel unlimited to game pass and gdc
news to discuss so we're going to get
right into it
i want to introduce
four amazing ladies in the realm who not
only showcase their passion with
informative gaming discussion but also
display a remarkable consistency with
fun takes from a mature female
perspective
introducing the creator and host of the
grown women gaming podcast
my fellow ladies of sports destiny and
now eldon ring
who will forever be remembered as
legends of the e3 rooftop party
live from well no longer washington how
did i find out cali
georgia mva and making their triumphant
return into the realm of the lords
my girls lady infamous l boogie charisse
and delilah hd aka grown women gaming
how are we doing sis
you got all of us talking at once
let's get it it's been a minute let's
start let's start we go let's start with
some lady first how we doing what's
going on ladies
paying bills pay these taxes panties llc
funds
time and streaming oh yeah
yeah isn't it a problem with girl
we will talk about that that is a
headache
it's it's positive but it's it's a lot
of stress but you can't let you talk
about it yes yes yes we we multitasking
over here but uh i'm doing well i'm
blessed nice i'm i'm happy to be here
this morning with these lovely lovely
gentlemen and my girls i'm ready to do
this let's get it you already know we
gotta talk some nine to talk with the
hell they doing over there but anyway um
dude i gotta talk to the whole girl
let's talk to charisse how we doing i
see you doing big things out here sis
what's going on with you what's up
what's up good afternoon everybody
that's right thank y'all for inviting us
yes yes of course of course everything
doing good what you've been playing
what's going on with you oh my god
playing games well
working and playing games and
trying to i guess survive
that's real that's real no doubt no
doubt and of course haven't talked to
the homie in a while l bugs how we doing
l boogie how are you doing what you been
playing what's been going on with you
what's up um pretty much
eldering
24 7 i guess right like i haven't been
able to pick up anything else you know
we just got a tunic which i have been
waiting for forever but i
have yet to hit play
uh we got the new storyboard
snowboarding hit uh which i don't know
if it's gonna be a hit but you know a
new snowboarding game you know
internationally that shredders spreaders
right but i just downloaded it and just
haven't touched it i mean eldering is
just all-encompassing i and you know
i was probably the never souls
like me like never i'm not playing this
i'm not like
there was ones i couldn't even get past
the first boss but oh yeah this one is
totally different it allows you to you
know
get you get your toes wet first
dip your little pinky toe in for a
minute you know what i mean
yeah
then scale up so uh now i'm a big beekee
okay
142 in the house oh she's outside yeah
she's right more than me oh don't get
forward in game this is thanks to lady
lady lady you know oh let me pull it up
oh so lady like lady is like your attic
for us
yeah okay okay okay i got yes
that's a big car
what's funny is like people always talk
about how like broken magic is and elden
ring that's king i got a shield sword
combo that i don't care what kind of
magic combo you have like
this is the most broken things i've ever
seen in any type of souls game like i
can literally take any boss attack for
the most part there's obviously some
criterias but i will literally sit there
and i i was playing i was helping
someone uh on lfg yesterday and i'm
sitting there with my shoulder he's like
yo he's about to do that attack i'm like
so
yeah yeah i had to call i had to call
big bro when they jumped they robbed me
they took my chain i had to call back
even
though with you like you saw i wasn't
moving yeah like it was hilarious but
anyway but back to adults back to books
so it's been you as a non-soldier person
to see you kind of get into it it's a
big deal yeah yeah yeah it's it's
it's a big deal because now i'm all in
and i can't wait for them to bring out
another
game that's similar to this i'm hoping
that they stick with this
this setup because it definitely allows
for more people to get into the game
i think they will i think they
understand a niche right now right
they're appealing to all the bases now
yeah because right now this is like game
of the year right now right like
especially with all the delays
i think i think they
i think they found a really unique way
of casualizing the game but still
keeping whole uh true to its forms right
no doubt i don't know i think it still
isn't easy like you're not i think me is
not you never say but i think he's gonna
i think the next one's gonna be straight
up a regular souls game yeah
yeah
yeah okay
here's the thing though like
they've seen success but this is big
money success oh this is like yeah this
is different it's a different level
this is the kind of success
this is the kind of success that
some developers aren't he might be one
of them that's like
yo let's double down let's let's do more
of this kind of stuff yeah you see that
type of yeah what's up before he was
going hand to hand on the corner now oh
yeah
he distributed worldwide
big facts no doubt good to see l rocket
and rolling no doubt and of course last
but not least lady delilah hd the big
big homie what's going on
what's up what's up glad to be here
thank you for uh
for bringing us before we get started
how about you hit me up on that bill fam
like you sent me to the end i'm trying
to get it i'm level um 121.
so yeah i'm trying to i'm trying to you
know get get my game
oh he's talking about yeah well see the
crazy thing about it is like
i was originally running with the
moonville and it's broken and then
people sit there telling me how broken
it is like i had i would have minor
success but yeah i gave him the
moonville thank you turn your bike a
little bit down cause they're gonna get
back his bike is yeah he's speaking his
mic is peeking i can't my ears you know
i didn't get it
yeah but i'm i'm doing pretty good you
know just doing counting some life stuff
recently moved i'm just trying to get
things to get adjusted so yeah
speaking of which i don't know if y'all
want to disclose this but the chancellor
which one of them is from va
i'll be me oh books put it out there all
right because so relax yourself calm
down
cut it out
yes
he can go half a va he's like hey what's
up
yeah that's exactly yes
continue the life how everything been
going otherwise what you're playing
what's going on with you you know just
working you know taking care of things
doing games like elder rings number one
i tried shredders can't get can't get
jiggy with the controls
can you talk real quick about that you
know what really disconnected me
i never had to get beside the control
which we're gonna tell we gotta hold the
button thing hop hold of a bumper come
down all this crazy i'm like all right i
just want to do the snow and some good
beats that's what i wanted to do right
so you mean you mean controls that are
standard and like almost all these all
right all right but he doesn't know
i don't snowboard like that so i didn't
know that's what it is just remember
1080 yeah
you're you're you're oh oh i thought you
were talking about eldon reed no no no
no no no i'm talking about snowboarding
i'm talking about
yeah
so the
so here's the thing like they think the
live disconnect to be like i don't know
if it disconnected you
the dialogue was getting on my nerves
the hand holding i'm like like just let
me play the game
it's a lot it's like this dudes haven't
had i mean in its defense
dudes haven't had a good snowboarding
game in a long time
is in the middle for some people because
i tend to lean a little bit on it i see
the people i mean you mean it's it it's
lukewarm yeah yeah
it's soft
it's a different it's a diplomatic way
of saying hey whack
is it that the controls are just they
try to simulate too much
it's not arcadey enough no yeah it's
convoluted it's coming
what you think i think this is i think
it's they try to simplify it simplify it
and it's a it's an indie you know they
tried to put a lot into it you could
tell they put a lot of thought into like
the snow and the atmosphere
those controls and then you can't even
change the controls that's my problem
what about the accessibility yeah he
knows a lot of things i gotta i gotta
get nice
[Laughter]
relax baby just joking calm down anyway
so all right so cool everybody been
rocking and rolling you know we got the
four horsemen of gaming those original
lords of the realm here at the round
table my calls with the colmos my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man lord addict of the attic show and
pulling up to get my chain back from the
golden lancelot dude in the beginning
what's going on bro
doing pretty good man uh you still only
got like worse
it sounds it sounds like you're not
using
the regular mic it sounds like yeah it's
like extremely loud like i've never no
it's it's on that mic yeah just i don't
know if you got to turn your um short
your own paw track down a little bit but
yeah
oh yeah crazy
[Laughter]
what about now oh no dj kelly no shot
try your um did you try like your yo or
what you call it i did oh
i'm gonna just start getting like one of
those windows
like voices to talk for me i'm just
gonna type in it it just talks for me
instead speaks
then you chat can't get on to me every
comment section because at that point
it's not me
it's the windows controller it sounds a
little scratchy yeah it's like booming
and scratching a little bit yeah it's
really loud maybe just pull the bike
back a little bit i don't know i mean
it's literally this far
it's so weird
let me see talk down from that distance
l give me six feet
good
nothing
okay okay keep going mic check hello
there we go let's do that let's do that
let's do that
let's do that but anyway so now that you
got my chain back what else you been
doing you know elder wrang still what
you should be doing i mean i got
i have um one more
demigod to be i don't know if you guys
have seen on twitter the chick that
constantly does like the sword attacks
like yeah i'm fighting her right now and
uh look my sword does good but she's one
of the exceptions because this is she
she hits you so much that it will go
through all of my statement keep in mind
i have bosses hit me that take like
like a hair of my stamina she's hit me
like 50 times it's taking my whole
standing bar almost wow uh he's supposed
to be the hardest right lady yes yeah
yeah i had her like this much health and
then she jumped up and did another
attack i'm like man someone tells it
like the good thing is she's easy to
stagger but like the part that makes her
horrible is when she hits you she gains
some of her health back yeah
it doesn't even matter if i have my
showed up she still gets it that's
ridiculous oh i'll have my showed up
she'll getting her health back i'll get
her like almost down to a good point
then she does that crazy combo and gets
like half her health back that's
ridiculous you gotta dive duck dip dive
and dodge
[Laughter]
that dodge ball right but you beat it
though you beat it though right it's
done now right no i'm still i'm still
fighting her like she she's an optional
boss guy not like like she's not only
the regular game he's just out here
he out here trying to get the i'm trying
to get the rest of the achievements and
trying he's like
the only reason i'm doing good against
her is because i i stagger her which
does a lot of damage and then i have a
bleeding effect that does a lot of
damage so she rarely gets the amount of
health that i'm taking from her but like
the
it's pretty much a battle of attrition
who's going to fir who's going to go
down first first hire me and so far it's
been me every time
no doubt
and of course we have the most technical
gaming lord the solo game who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus lord of clarity and
lord patron of the iron bank my mid lord
sovereign how we doing sir
i'm good chillin i haven't played any
damn games
what's going on with the schedule bro
you know how it goes you know i i
actually last night late last night i
downloaded tunic i was like let me just
i gotta play tunic like
um and i got to play maybe 20 25 minutes
of it oh right
and that's the thing even starting off
right i managed to find a little uh just
a little stick to use as my sword i
haven't found the actual sword yet right
but just in that beginning area if
you're willing to to sort of search
around and explore there's a lot of
different paths to find like it is
really intricate in terms of hey once
you get all your weapons and stuff and
you can start like cutting down shrubs
and opening up other pathways like
there's so much to find in this game and
i'm literally 20 minutes in like so this
ain't no super lucky tails qt this is a
real oh that was that straight platform
comparing stuff no because you know how
people see something 20 22 but you know
i'm not saying like it's whack i'm just
saying like you know some people see
something adorable looking
like oh this is a happy experience i'll
have you do your slander no it's not
slow
lucky's tail is cool i like lucky's tail
but it's straight up it is missing with
that you missed me with that lucky
though
you're too sensitive
no i'm not you know what it is oh we're
gonna get into too sensitive in a minute
oh we're gonna get to that too
it's my turn
um yeah so just that little bit i can
tell the exploration is gonna be crazy i
know i'm gonna find some crazy secrets
but again let's see if i can play um
this is my first week back in the gym oh
that's why you ain't playing no games
it's awesome bro you know you don't know
i didn't i haven't touched weights yet
you know i had to i got to try to get my
lungs back yeah
jump rope
burpees yeah mountain climbers um
death
in life and they're moving like what the
hell am i doing anyways you know that
you know that yeah yeah look if you even
say the words
[Laughter]
and that's the reason i stopped right
when i got married it's like she loves
me
[Music]
that was a big mistake so
you know trying to get my lungs back is
not fun because it's like you just
laying on the ground dying burning
um but it feels good though but you know
afterwards i feel energized and i'm like
okay damn why did i ever stop but you
know it feels good good good to see you
you know what's funny you know what the
ultimate workout is so
just having like you know the um
groundhog i get like we repeat the same
day over and over again just repeat e3
like five times in a row
that's great cardio
one day at e3
yeah just walking around
i mean we're about to do that now it
impacts drugs don't
[Laughter]
no doubt and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
gamer oh the prophet of xbox swami
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord k how are we doing sir
stress the hell out
i'm stressed the hell out i'm stressed
out with a hope it was supposed to be a
watch in a fight yesterday i do not like
watching fights in the morning after the
fact because i got a duck dodge dip and
slide away from people that's playing
elder ring with me trying to give me
information so i i'm just like nah miss
me with that miss me with that i'm not
looking at your dms how about that nope
not gonna touch that so i gotta watch
these shows in these fights and i
watched them it was really good fights
yesterday um
got a whole bunch of stuff going on and
i got to leave early today because i got
a whole bunch of stuff going on
got a whole bunch of stuff going on
tomorrow and the day after and it feels
like i'm doing e3 all over again before
pax happens so this is kind of crazy but
i got my gaming in let's go and and i
can't lie
my days my waking day sleep
and and and and just subconscious
thoughts is elden ring oh which really
sucks because
if if you if you're sleeping and you're
saying to yourself damn i could beat
that boss if i roll to the left
exactly i i i completely agree about it
right
waking up thinking about it
the game challenges your thought process
and how you actually attack a boss
normally if a boss hit you in your face
you like hold on back up a second wait a
second let me get away from this
and they want you to do that they want
you to try to get some distance on them
so they can beat you up some more
nine times out of ten you're supposed to
either roll forward or just be calm in
in the heat of battle and step to the
left or right and always keep your eyes
on your opponent that lock-on feature i
realized that's the devil why i learned
i learned
how to use the future well you don't
even use it no because you engage andy
and take it off like right you have to
you have to selectively use it for
certain enemies kind of sorcerer you
guys done right now
man
there's al there's always bosses that
you want to naturally de-aggro because
like the camera angle is going to be an
issue like the fire giants one but man
especially those humanoid you people if
if i try to fight them on camera i would
probably break everything around like
right like i'm just gonna miss you
now
because i have a great sword that swings
wide pause oh we'll see i use a i use
the katana for the majority of the game
so it was like precise
i don't i use it when i want to inflict
bleed but anyway i just got to say
shout out to kidsmove move
oh florida don't kiss me
cut out for the kids move what can't do
for not knowing
that there's certain arrows for certain
bows
right and he had attic
i'm i had the headset on right so this
is what happened attic and i was
supposed to have a session
excuse me
but he was helping kid at first so i had
jumped on a little bit late he said yo
king don't worry this is going to take a
couple of minutes
yeah three hours later
i know when my man is frustrated when he
just stopped talking your kid is in the
shot laughing
and he was so frustrated with kidding
i'ma walk
listen i'm gonna do as much damage as i
possibly can
and then it's up to you
he had a little bit left
and he died he said exactly be like all
right he i'm dead
and then kid go oh oh my god you you
know hey addicts like jump on your horse
call us oh
do something
okay this is it we're going to king's
world after
3 45
but i had to leave
after you got off i was like i'm out
i was like i was like the red giant is
your problem
oh damn you ain't getting back oh they
lfg people
they lfg it was you know you know what's
funny oh when you elegy someone you
could ask king we was running to the red
giant and i looked at the dude that we
lfg and i was like this dude ain't gonna
be all that like i don't see nothing on
him
oh you sized him up he looked at his
feet was like nah he died he doubt about
this then you could ask kate we was
fighting the right giant and then i was
like well the dude the new dude's dead
three hours they lmg people and it's all
fault it's all careful
because you know you hear the
frustration the kid is fighting in there
but it's funny listen to other people
play it but this that's what i've been
playing i played some tunic i was trying
to get some guardians of the galaxy in i
mean this game pass is really bombarding
me with too much to play at one time and
the fact that this this
this elden ring is here and it's being a
barrier to play anything else it's all
consuming and it's and it's crazy
because i'm not a souls person at all
i ran from those blood blowing i
couldn't beat the werewolf in the front
right in the beginning
and and
attic eloquently brought it to my fraud
attention it's what's supposed to be
supposed to run past him
you mean the big yeah that's it's a
troll boss they put it there to trick
you
to fight him when you i mean you could
beat him but i don't recommend you try
that's the dude that you saw me kill on
uh me and uh congress fighting on oh
yeah the dude took by the trade we gonna
get to be a minute um so that's what it
is okay
yeah no man
that's it um i'm going to do some stuff
today and i'm going to get back on
eldering because
he's everybody is 260
175 and and my butt is running around
like i don't know i'm like what probably
one fifteen one ten but i'm i'm complete
savage i'm a complete sound i'll watch
you you're like
i didn't stream this week i apologize to
everybody i'm going to stream again this
way and attic is going to teach me how
to save so y'all can go back and laugh
your behinds off on the old head playing
new games yeah looks like
i was like
no doubt and of course we've got the
gaming ninja himself the [ __ ] don't be
lord cognito spreading that real estate
around of iop not telling what you want
to have what you need to hear shout out
to mr maddie plays defile it dude we had
a good one just talking about what's
going on with all the sony acquisitions
and new witcher and then arguing about
what sodas is the best which was
hilarious they wrote that in that's kind
of funny um shout out to the last word
ebonitus thai guy travis had my homegirl
uh nope talking she was hilarious great
show spicy destiny talk and all that and
then for me
just force did you play stream like you
were supposed to force to play a game
stream yeah it's up sir what you talking
about
it was i didn't see it on the iop
channel i know i tried to promote the
twitch channel sir oh okay okay
we have something called restream server
for a reason also is there a problem
that it's on twitch
[Music]
there
has to go through a program that
distributes to those outlets educate
them and educate them
educate them
i wasn't tagged so i couldn't get a
chance to well the iron podcast didn't
tweet that account sir so i was paying
attention but anyway but anyway but
anyway well anyway
there was nothing live that i saw it was
live
that y'all guys don't know tech it's
cool but uh we're gonna move forward
we're gonna move forward but um yeah
look you know y'all know how i feel
um i've been very staunch in my stance
as far as you know i just didn't think
it's a game for me i will say this after
playing it for about two or three hours
look it's a fun game it's a fun i'm not
gonna sit here and be disrespectful the
game is fun
i get the appeal you know say it for a
hardcore souls fan
open world
you the best fun i had in it was
actually just running around in a town
with nights and they i was i made my own
storyline i was like oh they
they sack this town i was like i gotta
liberate it right so i'm fighting around
you know what i'm saying i'm doing my
little thing so then one dude i slice
and king you remember the oh oh
i was like oh he did the oh he called he
snitched on me in like nine people
so i said oh this is crazy so i go for
it that was the most fun i had was that
portion right there you know what i mean
and like i said i completely get it but
i
have
issues
talk about it the dick listen the game
is great
but it got a lot of 1998
energy like it's just like
like simple things in 2020 like 2022
like there's no clamber
like the control is clunky fair though
when it comes to the clamper there's not
a lot of third-person stuff that has but
like there's a right to this in front of
me and i hop i can't get on top of the
rock oh yeah like like come on like it's
20 22 like the thing is i get it for
what he's doing but it's like i feel
modern game design we allowing a lot of
stuff to stay archaic because we love
everything else about the experience i
agree that that's my joy and it's like
no one's calling this out now remember
i'm coming from a noob perspective no
souls game in 2022 there's certain
things as to me is unacceptable like i
feel the ui is a little clunky i feel
the control is clunky i feel like a
little slow i feel like that he said 98
was a good get a good year though
a lot of people consider 98 the best
year in gaming yeah bro it's like again
i'm not trying to be disrespectful it's
one of those things addict and we talked
about it like
some things intrinsically as an older
gamer because i'm a gen x gamer i just
know it's not for me i just know all
right that's that's cool you know what
you know everyone
what did joe brain say because he was in
your infancy
level 10 in the head
so what did you do seeing the gold dude
on the horse because i saw him and said
oh hell no no i went to the right
what did you say my thing was i can't
have him running around outside
d-blowing mad slow with the golden armor
like you're not going to just be in the
town like no one's supposed to step to
you like i just i my ego couldn't have
it that's how
that's how you know called don't play
these type of games because when you see
someone looking all extra you go the
other way
you know
i had you just test this [ __ ] real quick
what did he say
it's like boy if
let me test the physics let me let me
get hide in between this rock it's
here's i know i'm coming up there with
the horse and i'm getting your body
wait okay
you did this with no horse nothing i'm
outside hell no he jumped he jumped
right off the cliff right down and debut
sword brand new fresh in the face fresh
in the face what's up what's up i'm
outside let's
you didn't accidentally skip the the the
tutorial though right i didn't do that
no i didn't did you just love it
so what it is they help it is like just
get outside because i was inside the
bottom part it was like just get outside
do what you got to do because they
wanted me to explore more you know what
i'm saying now once i let my ego go and
left him alone then i went to go explore
the world and i go from that part i was
having fun like i said i was making my
own little stories whatever again good
game
souls fans i get it i know it it's just
it's not it's not for me
like i like big lore character
development story like this is very
light on the narrative side you know say
it for me and like i said but i
understand the appeal i understand i
will say this there's only one game that
i've been completely
wrong about and i when i played it and i
was like this was it was probably
fallout but this one i knew this was
what this was you know i'm saying but
everybody still had a good time
definitely not the story though even for
me because like i couldn't tell you i
can't tell you
yeah one thing i can't tell you why i'm
here what i'm doing for what reason
i don't think i don't think so
i don't think a hardcore souls fan can
ever tell you what that looks about all
i know i woke up and they call me your
talish get in there your tarnish
peter get your weight up [ __ ] that's all
true the thing is though is this game
has a real any souls games there's a
really bad
thing where they're like we want you to
read the details and weapons we want you
to read the descriptions and everything
kind of like a lot of like the destiny
lore is like
it's just like so he should be used to
it right
oh he's like like
oh let's go
she ain't been away she went
i've started searching like you said i
have to have a i have a goal when i play
in elder ring but
there is no
even my little bit of a story like i
started like three quests and i have no
idea don't know what the hell you doing
i can't i can't say it doesn't it at
least yeah i can go back to my uh
talk about that so that's happening
where i need to go or
yes that's that's the beauty of it this
story oh that's the beauty but we let's
get to the elephants in the chat like
[ __ ] that's really that i can't believe
you listen we're going to talk about
this co-op
we're going to talk about this car well
you got to i got to throw my finger on i
got to
be here on thursday
come on
it is worse than nintendo switch energy
how bad that co-op is
i mean you gotta go find his little
symbol
and then you gotta click right here
so when you go into multiplayer you go
into settings the people you're playing
with need to have the same multiplayer
and if it's a group that you play with
often it needs to be in that next the
next
level
you have them there that way your
particular one will have a nice halo
around it so i know that's it okay and
then i got to put the code and then make
sure i stand on this corner on this
block one thursday once you put the code
in that's it actually yeah it's actually
more complicated than that
how it goes is eldon ring has this thing
where it's like it the person not too
low this is funny
yeah
they don't i'm sorry i'm sorry
they don't want unwelcome people playing
with people i mean this is unless you
get the password from an individual to
get in isn't that better yeah much
better good at it perfect
and they touch your little gold symbol i
think that eliminates a lot of you know
because cog what do you deal with
like unwanted customers but talking to
people that they shouldn't be talking to
yeah
elden ring you can't do that
well i mean you're gonna have people
invade you all the time no i'm not
talking about those people those people
are just wicked
i'm just i'm just tired of people saying
but it's always been like this like this
is unacceptable
[Laughter]
it definitely needs to be i i don't i
don't understand the mindset where it's
like if you're going to let people play
in your game why you make it so
complicated like it's just like i i
don't get like no i don't think it's as
bad as switch because you need like you
need like a 15 digit code i have to
write you a password
but but you both come up with that
and you only have to do it one time
but like like you only have to do that
initial setup thing one time you put
down the the multiplayer thing and
that's all like i just i i don't think i
don't think it's an issue but i do
understand like look if people want a
more simplistic system i don't
understand the from software fans that
just say deal with it no yeah exactly
that's because they have brand loyalty
thank you
eastern rpg thing compared to a western
rpg thing where everything is a little
bit more simplistic because y'all just
uh mentioned
every american stupid i'm sorry no no
i'm just saying that
not even that it's not about the menus
yeah about that we tend to try to make
things and
a little bit easier like progressive
wise and they try to stay uh stuck in uh
tradition i know where you're going
so the tradition of it keeps them stuck
with doing a bended finger to mix it in
a potion to get a compass to do the
compass to say hello and then we look at
it like nah how about we just say invite
how about we use the
ui and operating system that is
available for all the games
like what king said like that's part of
the lore too like you're in this world
everything is magic and all this other
stuff you gotta dip your fingers
i get that but at the same time this is
a video game so it's like i can't go you
can't say that though
but the thing is though it's not just
because it's part of the game there's no
information on how it works
i was running around with a bunch of
fingers ain't no what i had to do for
instance me and cog had the exact same
password but because i played it i knew
what was wrong but i was trying to
finesse it where
how it works is like since i was trying
to get him in my world because he didn't
have the uh the souls to get what he
needed to go i had to go grind to play
the co-op
i had to earn the right to co-op the
funny part is my world
when i would when i would pop one of the
compasses to see his symbol it wouldn't
show up because the world of elden ring
was reading my world and said yo you
beat every boss you don't need no
multiplayer partner so he wouldn't pop
up like you can't just have someone show
up for no reason like there's gotta be a
magic game knew what you were trying to
do and stopped you
i'm mad that they incorporated a co-op
system into the game but it's got mad
conditions
oh my god i agree with everything that
she's saying
i just here's the thing like it would be
different if they told you they're like
look if you have a boss they don't tell
you none of that like if we didn't know
that me and kyle could have wasted two
hours just which we did on the screen
co-op game when all it would have took
is a simple thing it's like look there's
a reason he can't join your game and
they just have a list of conditions that
you can't join they don't say none of
that and i get it people's like that's
the that's the beauty of elderly
that's the beauty i don't understand
withholding information makes the game
better it doesn't like i just don't get
that you're still 240 though
there you go
that's something it has something we go
move on
look i get it
it's doing phenomenal i love that people
who have never played souls games are
playing it i think instinctually being
able to be played
that's all i'm asking you no i can play
with you i know before you play no no
i'll play with you because you know i'm
not going to play unless i play with
y'all so
that's just where that's at with it but
um anyway look we were running old
enough so let's get into it but now that
we've been focused on elden ring and
what the laws have been played just real
quickly because it's been a minute you
know since we had gwg in the building
growing women gaming so um yeah i think
it was like two years ago like episode
140 or something 145 and just real i
wanna do a little something different
real quick because it's been a minute
and you know a lot of new people that
don't know who the ladies of the realm
are just real could tell everybody you
know what you guys stand for with gwg
you know the longevity you know 200
episodes and also things y'all got
cooking what's going on in your world
each year
okay um
for me um
the thought that even the thought of it
was like 2015 2016 around that area um i
just started streaming and i was looking
for women that look just like me that
plays video games at the time i didn't
see any so
um i'm just thinking about a grown woman
game and growing on the game and i was
like okay so um actually i got the name
from chase chase money oh chase
yeah okay so i
one day i asked him i said is anybody
using that name he's like no why why
what
so we started off with it was just it
was just a saying just growing and
gaming i would you know shoot it to the
mountaintops um
then i met l boogie 0208
we used to do friday night uh game
nights just me and her playing the call
of duties the battlefields the destiny
love it
then um delilah came into the fold
because we met before doing
other podcasts in the past i think it
was a lady council corner if i'm correct
delilah
and uh
and uh i approached her i was like come
on man i got girl mommy gaming and she
would she the one that was like you
gotta let me know this is real you gotta
let me know like you're not just playing
she was serious about she was like oh
you well you got to show me how serious
you want to do this growing me with me
gaming thing
so
we did our first few episodes of growing
the gaming on grg and then we moved it
to my channel
and then now we have our own channel we
do our shows every sunday we have our
patreon merch store
saturday 9 a.m
noon eastern next thing on saturday
morning we got the merch store we got
the llc we got the website we got the
discord we got the game nights
hopefully we can expand
that's right that's right we're putting
the links in the description right now
go get that go sign up yeah something
around that's right we want that look
but we want that 2022 lookbook and we
can't do it without you exactly
okay
um
i have not seen a consistent podcast
with women in the past five years like
us i'm gonna to my little horn here
because this is not it's not an easy
thing um you can always collaborate you
know anybody can collaborate with one
person or a few people to do a show but
it takes hard work dedication
discipline and willing to learn from
your your counterparts to do a show
every saturday we on year five i think
we on year five now absolutely
so it is tough and i will not trade
these ladies for anything in the world
anything that's what's up i love that i
love it
i love this [ __ ] i love to see it let's
let's move to delilah real quick just
for you personally like what is real
women gaming meaning for those other
audiences that are not familiar with you
guys like
but talk to me it's everything because
um prior to joining gwg i had i had my
own websites i was doing like a media
blitz had my own company doing all these
things within the gaming industry i just
on my own charisse was my writer and
miss we used to go way back because we
went to college together and whatnot
um so that's how we connected but it's
everything for me now it's it's like
it's my thing because i don't stream
so you know i'm not big on on that whole
scene and so yeah i'm the producer of
the show
and um it just i put my all into it so
if you see like the graphics that's me
if you see you know like the website you
know gwgpodcast.com oh by the way that i
love podcast design that y'all see that
was inspired by the lila hd she gave it
to me thank you appreciate the cool
information i had my eyes bleeding
but it was it was it was sisterly love
he was like
y'all gotta fix that let me give let me
give you a suggestion that was nice when
you enjoyed this whack with this
diplomacy very different about it
you did it absolutely
yeah yes
and so um i did prior to joining gwg
like i didn't battle with other little
other podcasts you know they'd take for
a minute then you know recipes grg
to cal yeah
so so it's everything
i can do it without these ladies we're
very um communicative like we we talk
every day we to make sure that we're on
point and especially now that we're a
business it's it's all even more
important i mean i'm pretty sure you're
all familiar with that too just
communication is huge huge yeah i
absolutely love it you know thanks
everybody for the support
yeah good to see y'all shawn and no
doubt let's get l bugs who the lord's
definitely got a lot of history with
what does gwg mean to you and talk to
the people who are getting familiar
learn about y'all for the first time
um so gwg for me is
[Music]
i don't know it's
just like the lady said we
don't really see a lot which there are
out there i'm not going to say there
aren't female-led podcasts out there
because there are
out there but um within the space that
we operate there there aren't many
especially for women of color
who um
hold themselves to a high standard i
would say
that we make sure that um
the things that we're talking about
are um
not just the fluff
not just the console war stuff we talk
about everything um we even i mean
mainly we're probably one of the more
business heavy i would say podcast
a lot of technical knowledge whatever
podcast
so you're not going to come to our
podcast and hear just opinion opinion
opinion
you're going to hear facts you're going
to hear
technical knowledge you're going to hear
business knowledge um i myself have a
degree
now
we're not talking about we we just
talked we educated over here
talk your talk
yeah you're gonna hear a business jargon
and all that so uh if you wanna come
listen to us which i will encourage you
know you are gonna get some knowledge
there
just listening to the ladies
but um all of our ladies i i love all
these ladies like we've we've become
real tight friends uh
which it was it didn't start like that
but you know we've just been together
and with this common goal of creating a
space for women
women of color to talk about games has
uh brought us together so um
and i i know you guys from
just
going to e3 you were one of the first i
saw off the plane my very first e3 uh
yeah that's this is dope this is dope so
we got a ton of fun so yeah oh yeah
you're doing that rooftop i miss it
i get to pack so i think the goal for
next year is gonna do packs uh i wasn't
able to go to pax this year because the
ladies we had our little vacation went
to tennessee
[Music]
i was like okay
of course of course we would find a
borrower with the arcade right
when you get to pax you're gonna realize
how
intimate it is
y'all going to like it a lot i'm going
to look forward to that i'm looking
forward to that because it's because i
don't know for me i don't really know if
i even want to do e3 somewhere
especially after i would have turned
into yeah yeah because of what it's
turning into right um
mm-hmm yeah so
i look there for that it's gonna give
you that vibe
um that old school vibe that that okay
okay it's very short lines very it's a
ton of people there right but it's two
three people waiting for the game
opposed to a line for two hours waiting
for a game right and they have bigger
games they're larger scope games aaa
games but
it's it's it's a little bit more
intimate yeah
to talk to the developer one-on-one or
the media personality that's there to
help you out and give you technicalities
about the game it's it's incredible
stuff it's a whole lot different and i'm
glad that it stayed in that vein because
i really don't like what e3 turned into
yeah i forgot it's good to hear someone
else feel the same way because you kind
of feel like bad right because of all
the
everything that's come with e3 all the
camaraderie we've gotten as far as like
people we actually know we've seen this
person in real life so when i tell you
that i've met this person it isn't just
virtually yeah um but yeah absolutely i
think yeah i think you're gonna enjoy it
it's really fun different type of feel
like king said very intimate
let's ask my home girl charisse one of
the best writers in the game what does
gwg mean to you sis
um it means family um
these are my ladies right here um like
i love them like there's no they've
already said this we've said this dozens
of times um
i don't know what i would be because
again they were the ones who pushed me
to all the extraneous i did last year
that award that i won oh these ladies
pushed me and had my bag when i was like
i'm gonna just
throw it all the way and it was like no
you got to get up and you got to do this
um kept me sane during the last year
these ladies right here
um playing video games and chatting
throughout the day
and listening to me ramblo about the
craziness that is the library world
yes
we'll be bringing them ps5's to the
library they be getting it in
your library
okay so we've talked about this a lot on
our show but i live in the deep south
like i am literally literally 45 minutes
from the florida border so i live
basically in a swamp um a lot of my
community does not have
high speed internet like some places are
still using dialogue wow so one of my
clerks bought a playstation 5 and i was
like after i cracked some jokes on him
because you know
he was like he was like he was like man
i can't download any games i can't do
any of this i said it's okay bet bring
it to work one day and i will let you
hook it up to one of the um our system
here because we are the only place in my
town that has free wi-fi we have the
highest speed in anybody so i was like
just bring it to work run your updates
[Music]
do what you got to do and so
he's done it like three four times now
like because that time i posted a photo
that was like the second or third time
every two weeks he'll bring his system
and he'll run his updates and download
new games he's like miss torah can i
come tell me what games to get and i'm
like bad okay you should have told him
grand tourismo seven oh stop it
okay
it was bad he was trying to play um
watchdogs or something and it took like
a whole weekend for the download and i
was like
yeah they got the worst download
and i was like just pranking the work
just so he got a little bag and they're
just leaving here
oh he's got that
no he bought it he bought him a hard
drive
um that way he can download everything
onto the hard drive and like switch it
over and stuff but he has a um the fact
that this version okay
the the herniated one
the fat booty what y'all talking about
she said hold
gwg the ladies of the rounds and it's
the fabulous
y'all said it because we can't say that
it it's not natural it's it's like you
know brazilian you know
[Music]
he'll probably bring it back in the next
couple of weeks when some new games drop
but yeah yeah so it's going to be a
couple of weeks right yeah
the same thing weeks
weeks months y'all messy
hey
get a ui update
yo somebody in the chat said little me
and miss fat booty i'm done continue
hey that works
um so yeah
i never would have thought about that
because again gwg we understand that you
know not everybody has type of stuff
like that so we have to help our folks
out even though they you know play on
blue side we're still
still we're good
on gwg i am i want to say the because i
just bought a playstation 4 like maybe
three years ago right on the suggestion
of the ladies
um i still don't play it it's got dust
on it right now
she already got to come with it she got
it
she's clearly the king
she's clearly the king of the of gw
that's the petty one
she put her money in now it ain't her
fault that it ain't providing what
instead of you it ain't getting what
it's supposed to give yeah delilah
i feel for y'all
i know what it is the whole type of
treatment but i do want to play station
five i just haven't found one yet and
you got one if you got a pro playstation
4 pro
oh
wow
he said it no because there ain't
nothing different
jesus
but what
i wanted i wanted to celebrate you know
shari's because um you know before
before we went live and stuff and um
i wanted to celebrate your blessing
because just to see kind of like the
librarian you know like of the year the
employee like just to see the
celebration my home girl had the big
publishers clear house check i was like
oh she's doing big things right now
let's go you don't say just don't forget
me when you catch that don't forget me
well
it was cool to see you celebrate it in
your field and we definitely wanted to
celebrate your blessing on that and
that's that's really dope what you're
doing for the community as well awesome
no doubt no doubt real quickly because
been a minute i know we don't we don't
normally do the typical thing but i
gotta ask quick if we can for each of
y'all i need the top fives any updates
any changes i know i'm putting y'all on
the spot but remember a lot of people
are new here in the realm they don't
know the ladies in the realm they need
to know what type of games y'all rocking
so whoever's up ready first who got day
five ready
y'all could just jump in like these are
my five of all time
you got my first five right
off the top
it's not over time it's been it's been
two years
in there like no just
just for right now just
it's how you feel right now it could
remember this this list always evolves
it always changes it's just where you at
right now as far as of all time the five
that's personal to you you know
your favorite five i had the most five
favorite or five i'm playing right now
five favorite of all time your top five
go ahead
i got mine let's go to the left
you know she prepared
come on now i'm probably having she's
ready this morning
let's go let's get these top fives right
quick hello what's up right here right
now metroid swim that's right okay
that's right like
let's go let's go rank our nail time
uh legend of zelda ocarina of time halo
okay
um
frank you said french it could be
franchise franchise yeah games or
franchises
okay then
um
ninja gaiden
[Music]
um and last but definitely as you can
tell there's a theme going on with my
picks but
um it'll be ori so i'm a big
metroidvania fan
when when she said metroid i was just
like a soldier boy like dry
specifically specifically super metroid
though okay specifically that because
that because super metroid is the game
that got me into that whole
you know metroidvania of like getting
getting equipped
i had to beat that game at least about
10 12 times
ninja gaiden
specifically black because i just have
so much nostalgia with with that game
and then ogx box and they kind of got
that whole movement for me going yeah um
so yeah that'd be about five oh and i i
forgot the most important one before i
let open it up to everybody else lana um
console favorite console of all time and
why oh xbox ogx box oh gee
ooh
first
tell me why
you gotta explain yourself
um
because it changed my perceptive
perception on like where games could go
prior to that prior to that you know you
had like on your 2d 8-bit 16-bit you
know you had those type of games that
was releasing um and then playstation
came out i was one of those people that
weren't big on playstation um off jump
and i'm a non-conformist so because
everybody has something that's going to
try to go with other you are so similar
yo they call me a hippie
we go against the grade all the time
right i just wanted to be different you
know then i feel like you know
i was always a fan of microsoft which is
it's hard you know it's weird how things
align later on in life absolutely
it's it's
it's um yeah i from that i got inspired
to like create my own website and you
know try to see what's going on in the
media ranks um
everything so for me it was just it it
opened the door for me later on and also
inspired me to create and that's kind of
that's how i have the career now i'm a
ux ui designer and um
that inspired that you know like the
gaming inspired me to even make that
that decision oh good listen when you
break it down it's funny you say that
eog xbox is really important for pushing
the culture forward from a technology
standpoint from a social standpoint with
xbox live i mean watching the watching
the power on doc really made me remember
how significant it was at the time for
me it was it was doing features that no
other system is doing at the time but
where there's ripping music to your from
your cd to your hard drive
that the ui if you think about that ui
and this is this is how i got into ui
design but how they had the orb and you
selecting your your games from there and
stuff like they were just completely
unique no i hadn't seen that before from
any other like game system so it was
very inspirational valid
good choice good choice which other
grown
what i would i would do it i would do it
okay school lady top five mario
super mario world about new vegas
new vegas vegas
oh
city you talk okay all right you're
flexing them [ __ ] okay
specifically that way okay obsidian girl
i got you i'm with you i ran dead
redemption red dead
um call of duty black ops 2 because
now let's get before i stop playing call
of duty i played all of them so i had to
narrow it down so black ops 2
uh was the one i first got my master
prestige
um
and i'm gonna and what my fifth game i'm
i might i might have to sneak in elgin
ring in there
[Applause]
let's go
last three weeks was number eldering
nothing but i i became
somebody who
would used to be scared of playing those
type of games to someone who was very
familiar and very expertise on the game
and
so um that's i'm gonna sneak that in
there right now because that's where you
at
that's where i'm at that's where my i'm
at um my favorite console yes i'm gonna
lie it's gonna be the xbox 360 elite
black
she was specifically she's like the
elite black
elite black with the chat with the chat
pad i still got my chat pad
hey
i still got mice too as well as that's
right over there um
i'm gonna tell you why break it down i
grew up super poor so the only way i was
able to play video games like home video
games if i was at a friend's house or if
i was at a cousin house or i was at
somebody house you know
and my other way of enjoying that was
the arcade you had to go fire you had a
good like 20 you were good at the arcade
you know you had oh yeah
oh he was good
he was good yeah but um this is when i
first had a real job i had my own place
i had a nice little income tax return
and there was like okay i went to
gamestop they were like what you want
the playstation you want the xbox my
homegirl had the xbox i was like well
let me get this one but the black one so
it was
it was the first console that shut up
kids make sure mine is black shut up
shut up
king stupid
you heard me
with my home girl she had the gray one
and i
really was looking like
i'm not feeling that dirty and grimy no
and you finally got some and you can get
something that you really want don't you
want the best of what that is yes that's
right you want exactly what you want
that's right and that's what it was and
and
through red rings through the wireless
adapter
and the memories of playing xbox 360 on
that console that will be my favorite
you know
i love these
choices who up next who gonna put day
five on the line and they caught who up
your shoes i can go all right let's go
boogie with scott top five let's go one
of the best it better be pub g in there
because we had great times
one of the first games i like really
played and enjoyed and loved and fell in
level games with was uh duck hunt that's
oh that's an og
yeah yeah
and everything you know yeah right so
that was my first love there then going
on i would say super mario 3. that was
the one where you know you got the tail
and everything yes yeah um
so that was one of my faves uh delilah
ocarina of time um
same same that was like
really immersive oh yeah nintendo was
like
that was
the console i had a game boy i passed
down my game boy to my cousins and stuff
like
yeah game boy i was on it um
then more recently
i would say
um destiny has to be
yeah you were slandering i was very
offended what you said earlier i was i
know your history
[Music]
i love destiny but still at the same
time
tomatoes
um right now they're on the blue side um
even with the news
yeah please go get your girl what's
going on
i'm trying all right
the same oatmeal okay you keep handing
me the same oatmeal and telling me it's
different and it's not they put raisins
inside this time right right basically
i hate
yeah like how you just gonna take my
character change her voice and then
start making her look different and act
like i'm not gonna notice the
black character in the game is not
different that pissed me off because i
looked at her i was like what the hell
yeah i told you i was like yo are they
picking her darker now
what because i clarified that the
actress wasn't available anymore they
had to get someone that was frequently
available i mean not like they
deliberately tried to be a boozy yeah
they did
you could have kept the same aesthetic
look but right um change the voice i
feel like you know but they changed up
everything i was like did she go into
something i'm sorry
what are you doing i don't think i'm
stupid
at least at least
you understand
and i guess i should have known because
of how they did peter dinklage in the
beginning oh buddy yes yes you right
right see they got no kids they don't
care they walk away from the situation
finish your lesson i'm getting mad at
you
[Laughter]
go ahead now
i'm 34. i think i think i'm on four
right four
yeah okay so last one
um last one which i haven't even been
able to play lately
it would be apex um
i love that game like i love the way
that they do their storytelling because
it's not a you know single player game
at all but you have a ton of lore a ton
of little story with that game
um
and they continue to innovate right like
they continue to change the game to
make it more uh accessible to people
uh they brought in a ton a ton of
accessibility functionality in that game
um so it's much love much respect to
them especially for a game we did not
know what's coming right it's just like
here i am just dropped it
that's what show respawn was just could
do anything they'd be in a bag different
genres right i mean respawn is carrying
ea
factual and what we got for that console
greatest of all time for for l books
it would be a tie between
sega um
and the xbox 360.
and mainly the 360 because that's what
brought me back into gaming i took like
a huge break
in gaming
um mainly because for girls it was never
like
it's like why are you playing something
right it wasn't accessible to play games
and stuff like that so i definitely did
take a break from all the hate that i
received about playing video games but
um in the military i got close with some
folks who play games they brought me
back into the foe with the 360 and i
went full speed ahead so
um love it yeah without showing out to
our military bringing our people back
salute absolutely and last but not least
lady sharif i need that top five
now i did make a list while the ladies
were going through theirs
[Laughter]
um first of all destiny whoa oh first of
all
yeah first of all uh yeah i got issues
with it but that's still my game we're
gonna ride a dive and we'll fall off
um
this is specifically two specifically
no
but mass effect 2
um skyrim the only game i've bought with
three times
oh god
that's technically
i call black flag four but it's
technically called black but yeah you
co-signed it
for no no the only one better than that
one is assassin's creed two like
uh and then also dragon age two
okay i like that that's my top five and
my favorite console which is also
on my list
because it was the first one i actually
paid with my own money
i think that is very important talk
about it people don't understand that
part right there man you know somebody
can gift you something you know your
parents can do this and do that
but when you got that check and you walk
inside that store you know cash that
your money your pocket is bulging and
you you have a different swagger when
you walk in the door sound like a saloon
[Music]
and you put your money on that counter
you swipe your card or whatever however
you did it
yeah right
nobody can take that from you you're
right like that that's your purchase
this is your time this is you and when
you hook it up in the house is it
different turn on is it different
everything yeah and i believe that's
very important
it means a lot it means a lot absolutely
i like these last uh yes don't blame me
i killed that y'all killed that salute
to the ladies of the realm we got a lot
more show i had to reintroduce y'all
because you might have to do a raid win
yeah for sure hey hey hey what ray i'm
not ready
[Laughter]
it now soft look cue up on some of these
super chats
[Music]
oh you got them ready to go because i'll
do the pole i'm ready to go
one thing i want to say about our show
real quick
one of the main misconceptions of our
show is it only appeals to women our
show appeal to everybody is for
everybody
um you know our show we have industry
vets on there
that work in different uh gaming
companies microsoft execs the whole nine
so check us out when you get a chance no
doubt we're gonna put the link to the
chat one more time just in case they
forgot go subscribe go support the
ladies of the round grown women gaming
they out here doing big and you heard
what they said
men are allowed on the show just so
y'all know
this is
i'm glad that she said that because
they're legit they've been holding it
down we love the movement we love what
y'all been putting it down and it is
real opinions mature perspectives y'all
have fun when y'all need to but at the
same time like you learn a lot from the
show and it's cool to see you grow in
the consistency you know and like you
like you say i think lady said like you
know it's rare to see you know what i'm
saying especially for women of color
doing a podcast holding it down and we
gotta salute y'all tremendous
accomplishment llc gang too which is
huge people don't really know yo man
look
i i gotta make sure all the numbers and
all the paperwork is is correct and
that's a whole nother
that's a whole nother
that'll be solved for us thank god we
have solved oh boy that's right yeah he
definitely takes on that responsibility
yeah for sure i was mad that i thought
we should have been infamous i feared
but sorry i felt we should have cut
budget and you you had to make me play
elder ring
bank with gucci
[Laughter]
back to the ladies of the world again
hit the channel thank you also put their
channel up there put their twitter up
there please go support the lord sent
them and they've been doing it for a
while and they'd be out there it'll be
outside so salute to the ladies around
grown women gaming they still rocking us
we got some topics if solver is ready he
could do the super chats right now i
could jump to the poll whatever you want
to
do
i'm copying them one more thing just
yeah yeah
i'll be writing this no doubt no doubt
so last week's poll resulted in the
people spoken with the recent
announcement and gameplay reveal of
hogwarts legacy which of these games
posed the biggest challenge to elden
ring for game of the year 2022 the
winner of the four-way ilp poll at 50
percent of the votes kind of contested
god howard's bethesda 18 starfield
looking like it could be the true
contender to the throne coming in at
second place at 18 percent of the vote
was we already told you to stop the
fight game of the year been over eldon
king
coming next
they doubled down a couple days ago on
twitter the god of war's coming out this
year always so we okay so i gotta stop
putting it back in the next one
yeah
okay i gotta put it back in the mix i
ain't heard nothing that's only why it
wasn't in the mix this one but uh coming
in third place raising close 17 was the
harry potter fan stand up hogwarts
legacy looks amazing and in last place
14 percent of the vote was if big link
comes outside y'all know what that
breath of the wild to go do shout out to
everybody who participated lord addict
what are you thinking what are you
feeling they saying they saying
starfield could be that's the only only
one that could do i can't jump on the
star field bring the mic a little closer
now now you know this is crazy sorry i'm
sorry just break just bring it back a
little closer let's bring it closer i
don't know what's going on today but
we're gonna figure it out okay i i can't
get 100 on that's great
the
i i just can't jump a hundred percent on
star foot until i see
be diff like gameplay i do have a lot of
faith in that team
but it's just like this is something new
and we've seen
over and over again throughout the
generations like
sometimes when developers tackle
something new and put a new spin on
something they'd lose what made their
games games in the first place and i'm
not saying they're doing it because they
did come out and like you know that
roundtable thing they did got me
really you know confident that that's
not the case
but this is something completely new
it's not like they're making a far a
fallout 5 or an elder scrolls six right
now like this is star though it's a new
concept uh so they could easily
completely
destroy that or they could easily
execute it
i got to see gameplay before i'm 100 on
either one no doubt shout out to
fosurelli gaming he said the power of
bethesda compels you attic like he said
in the haddock show he said you need to
bend the knee to god howard stop playing
exercise stop playing but anyway solve
you ready some chance yeah ready to go
let's go
all right we got tazo ichi five dollar
super chat up past my bed time to show
supports the ladies of gwg lady infamous
delilah l boogie and cherise ftw let's
go
thanks to task let's go
let's go
then we got god's hit man
he's putting them down for the lord
please talk about the amd xbox
announcement no doubt we will talk about
that gdc
segment
and we got uh pilo 318 five dollar super
chat i don't have anything in there but
i i think we have one from him later on
so he said he agreed with him
then we got face 23 bkny 20 super chat
spartacus is not a game pass competitor
especially since being been reported by
bloomberg that no day and date games
will be on the service yeah i think they
were i think that's pretty much assumed
that's not happening
cedric h 10 super chat good to the
ladies in the realm with iop show is
going to be straight fire it already is
thank you sir appreciate that then we
got pilot 318 once again 10 super chat
dwg and iop this is going to be a
glorious sunday this is it salute
and we got tony bryant ten dollars to be
chat happy sunday lords ladies and realm
happy to be here live and to all to see
all my favorite people in one place what
i'm not happy to see is that light souls
has grabbed cog man
no no no i mean when you talk about the
lights so we'll talk about what happened
now
then we got mandingo makes the cross
as i look oh as i look over at lady's
office she's cracking up ladies every
time she hears that name she's like what
are y'all talking about
five dollar super chat just remember to
not wear spandex to the gym i think
these uh these are words to live by for
me um
otherwise you will be asked to leave
hashtag magningo mcphickens was asked
[Laughter]
i would love to have joined you uh both
the other day watching you against
ranella it would have been unfair uh to
to the queen azure
so i guess he was ready to jump in with
you guys oh that's what's up
johnny we got any time wave your finger
and we'll allow
then we have spartan go 17 five pound
super chat gem talk lightweight baby we
on 150 kilogram bench over here yeah i'm
not i'm not the weight dude you know
catch me in a month when i'm doing you
know pull-ups and all that stuff but i'm
not really the the heavyweight dude no
doubt
there we go clutch man five dollar super
chat i'll catch this on the replay have
a great show and shout out to gwg loving
guardians of the galaxy hashtag game
pass hashtag phil dominus maximus
aurelius
man out here winning
[Laughter]
then we got raidenblade once again five
pounds super chat eldon ring has
kidnapped every soul it's the black hole
of gaming i'm level 180 i have fallen
asleep many times woke up refreshed and
back to the action that's crazy kind of
crazy that's true
true
then we got tony bryant ten dollar super
chat never mama tell you what you need
to hear not what you want to hear throw
light souls in the bushes
i'm not feeling it
all that is they they thought they
thought they lost you for a minute they
got scared there no no no i was back to
the regular program i did my homework
i'm good he'll be back in there with us
this week
then we got raiden played again two
pound super chat if you're too heavy
good luck jumping or rolling that's true
yeah yeah the encumbrance there is real
like you gotta be light
then we got flame five dollars super
chat destiny story and soul story are
still kind of the same mostly in the
background but you'll have the hardcore
saying it's there anyways
cheers shout out to players shut up get
back to work
the thing that separates souls and like
destiny is
souls
they they do a decent job at explaining
like main scenarios but like as far as
like the world been
building like you have to pay attention
like descriptions and stuff and yeah i
feel like destiny used to be like that a
lot but here in the past like maybe a
year and a half they've done a lot
better
maintaining that balance
good do you then we have spartan ghost
17 once again two pounds super chat
games shouldn't have walls of text in
2021 i agree
all right then we have jean-marc louis
two dollar super chat
why do i need a manual for co-op that
ate that ain't itchy
tell the truth shave the devil continue
all right it's convoluted
then we have mandingo mcdickens once
again
the worst part of elder ring is the
co-op functionality there is zero reason
why we shouldn't be able to simply
invite like every other game
it's ridiculous that we can't ride our
horse talk tell the truth
don't worry about it it's ridiculous
that we can't ride a horse and they
scale hp and flasks
yeah you gotta you gotta accept the game
on its turn oh that's what we gotta do
old school development cool you know
what's crazy they they promoted this
like immersive world that they spent all
this money into
but if you
call someone in the middle of the world
they're like both you are or not
they got walking they got pagers in the
day of the cell phone
like like foreign
there's horses in the game like you
would have to get to a point like if you
call someone in the middle of like a
field or something they won't let either
of you jump on your horse so both of you
are walking and that map is
[Laughter]
this is why we can't have nice things oh
no no
it's their own community for not coming
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
this is dope i'm gonna go home and show
wifey yeah yeah people in the chat have
said that they're showing this podcast
to their wives
good women in the game talk about it
that's what i want to hear yes do it and
we want to see more i want to sub to the
damn channel stop playing
there we have pragmatic eagle 5 super
chat gwe is a must watch podcast the
ladies are so funny and their unique
takes are insightful and needed in this
community yes that is 100
thank you lord's work
then we have raiden blade again two
pound super chat cog don't hate on elden
ring you just need to level up okay good
get good bro get good bro
do better do better
do better
then we have gaming forte five dollar
super chat this isn't a sponsored read
in quotations the iop is my favorite
show on the net their dedication to the
craft is unmatched and as always hey
king boo boom
[Laughter]
let's go
[Music]
[Laughter]
let me roll back i got a couple of more
hold up
okay i got it hey 30 days of coach still
popping oh what's up
what are we doing oh no no no this is uh
the pellet
but this is the grown and sexy pillow
because we're always having to grow the
sexy show so i threw on the groin
casual it felt like a members-only job
tell them they're gonna make spaces
about that one tell them about that
we don't want to do them no more
what was that run go tell that what was
that
run to
super chat salute to the lords cog i
agree with you on elder ring bro some
things seem ridiculous with the game
breath of the wild is much better but to
each their eyes
oh my god
someone spoke that out
is so messy i love it she is so messy
very sparse
all i find i keep you just borrowing
stuff right
everything lay away
moving on
[Laughter]
why am i forced to read this read this
all right
don otaku five dollar super chat my
sucks spit and swallow game is on point
whoa after playing
excuse me
it's from other people though kirby
sounds like it should be rated m yes
yeah that's what i'm hearing you know
my whole mode
and knows because that was not coming
this way
switch really coming in hot
game game of the year curvy super bowl
but continue
he's enjoying it salute to him
remember for six months splendiferous
why attic sound oh loud on his show and
now he got the baby volley
follow him anyway you salute to the
ladies and lords of the realm and stop
it forte doing it big
no doubt no doubt
we got flame two dollar super chat just
trying to get a rise out of cog don't
shout out to the lords and ladies of
gaming bringing gwg on that's awesome
but panel please tell me your
acquisition wishes for xbox what studio
or devs do you want the most look like
activision
i want
i need a repeater sorry yeah what was
the uh acquisition yeah what
xbox debate studio wise or publisher
yeah i won't say activision because
that's already in the bag right pretty
much mm-hmm and now with all this hate
out here they don't matter it don't
matter what this is it ain't secure
when we walk down that aisle and lock it
in
it's happening all right it relax all
your muscles
okay
stupid
you got me yeah
i don't know which acquisition i'm good
like i'm good because i'm already like
at the point where i'm like i have so
much i'm eating like my plate is full i
feel like no doubt you know wb no no
ubisoft i
you know i would say wb because maybe
somebody can keep them to a proper
schedule
thank you that's what's
if this harry potter hit though then
it's going to kind of like defeat that
that this ain't even wb though like yeah
yeah
right exactly it's it's definitely not
yeah because like wolfenstein that's not
technically bethesda but they still get
the credit for it yeah
i mean but then you could say the same
for ea and respawn like
let's see some level anybody charisse
what you feel um
you already said mine mine is wb that
would have been my dream one because i
am a big batman arkham
um mortal kombat yes
so that would have been in my dream
studio right there i don't see it
happening but wishful thinking for sure
for sure delilah
late the fifth okay
what do you want
you'll be soft okay
attic what you want
i would like
i would like segue like on a xbox wise
but me personally if they bought missed
walker and had to make you know lost
odyssey 2 and stuff that's where i would
officially
solve this walkthrough
thank you yeah yeah everybody
i want the world i want you to
[Laughter]
i want to watch i want to watch twitter
just that's it
i want i just wish
i i wanted him to bring back all the old
ip in in in modern ways like yeah you
could do some side scrolling stuff like
those stuff but like you know you could
make like if you could take golden axe
right you could make a size call and go
to the next action game but you could
also take that create law around it and
make a crazy like article
so it's like it's things that they they
just kind of put them to the side and
just stop caring about but you can if
you move them forward and expand those
those universes i think they're very
cool
i could agree with that too because i
don't want like because people were like
oh i want this i want that like the old
stuff like i don't want the old stuff no
more like i'm the biggest proponent on
our panel that is like stop remaking
games
i don't want to see those innovates okay
okay
spicy
look i will say i'm in the middle i'm a
surprise you saw i'm actually going to
say wb even though my heart sega happens
that's you know no doubt but i think wb
is better um the family yeah
wb the dc and the fighting i i think the
thing the thing about wb is even though
the problem with wb is is like when you
think about the studios cool now when
you think about the properties on top of
that yeah yeah yeah but
phenomenal caveats yes yeah so it's like
um yeah if they can get they get the
life
fantastic absolutely let's get these
super chats we got both
lucious augustus five dollar super chat
so y'all don't want to read but then
complain that the game is convoluted but
skip the wall of text y'all didn't want
to read that's crazy
this is true this is true all right hold
on [ __ ] it jumped here we got mr
irishman member for nine months oh thank
you sir
souls haters simply net need to get good
it is get good bro nothing wrong with
the game it's perfect never level level
then we got jd gamer five dollars to be
chat lords and ladies specifically our
japanese games playing folks if
microsoft could have two companies from
japan one dev house and one publisher
who would it be
i know mine
platinum anyone
nah
why are you doing the platinum platinum
why plot the platinum y'all listen they
need they need a little help that's why
they just need a little help not our
help
she doesn't want that
xbox
i'm right i'm right there with him like
like
platinum is like that friend that you
stay away from and then like everyone
asks you know are they invited to the
cookout i don't know did you see oh did
anyone tell them they're invited to the
kickout disrespect
they can see the photos on facebook
afterwards oh
anybody got a suggestion any developer
any development house to the question
i'm not yeah i'm not big on the jrpgs
and japanese stuff so i will oh
i will i will take a pass at that cause
yeah i gotta say this one too okay i i'm
just
jrpgs
yeah that's how i feel
that's how i feel about other rings
everybody has that thing i can respect i
got you
if we reach in and this is a long ass
yes square enix oh
okay
i better need that one
like like maybe your platinum probably
would be a good investment too it's just
like you know we don't know what
platinum is under like consistency
we don't know what that type of platinum
is for real well i i get that but but in
the world of realism you're trying to
make qualities out of something that's
showing up
hold up
but look it's just like
it's just like studios
[Laughter]
oh god
it's just
you know she she showed that she she
can't cook oh
don't be disrespectful like that you
ain't gonna do that i mean we don't
brought recipes with a game tutorial she
got a couple of hits on the belt now
that i act like all the food
they need to they need to absolve
themselves of the b team
i would say miss walker
you know um to to get that i'll come
with attic all right cool let's move
because we got a lot to get we got it
okay so one more stop asking questions
jd gamer we got jd gamer 10 super chat
um panel if you could bring back one
franchise for a remaster and remake or
or remake what would it be also if you
could have genres a genre spotlighted
and focused on with games being added to
it what would it be everybody say this i
got to say this
why are y'all asking questions like
y'all don't normally try to be off yeah
i know yeah you know you notice that
yeah because we're here
[Laughter]
we get uh edible questions yeah or drunk
questions or weirdo questions
extra professional want to know what
state they react
to that it's either that or they think
oh they think we're stupid they're like
we finally got sparkle
questions
that's the fact song that's the fact
yeah i i appreciate the questions
because uh they know they they trying to
like really think like we don't know
what we're doing
here for a while right we've been here
for a while so we might not have the
same taste in games but we all
collectively know our [ __ ] yes and to
answer your questions
oh i'm sorry
i forgot you're good
you're good if there was a game there's
this franchise called blur
throwback game
it was it was a racing game with um
offensive concepts
and it was online i think
it was
i think they should bring that back okay
it's a throwback it's a real it's a it's
a real throwback
but i
i would love that
i mean those though that's bizarre those
are project gotham people yeah that's
all
that's that's love right there
no doubt no doubt cool
yeah
all right
we're still going yeah we still go come
on i got one so uh
if y'all remember the uh i know it's
it's like it probably wouldn't do well
in today's age but uh
um
dead or alive volleyball
well i know certain people love it for
other reasons
[Music]
[Laughter]
but it's only right it's only right
right we got it no it's not that's a
good thing isn't it you know what the
banana happens
[Music]
the thing is though is
there is a demographic of people that
will buy those yes that is true
when it comes to when it comes to having
men in it i don't know if there's like
the stretch of people oh you don't know
oh yeah
real quick just help you out real quick
uh females are 51 of the gaming
community
they will still have people who will buy
that game
i mean yeah the hell yeah i think you
should get out there mocap man put our
money out there
[Laughter]
doesn't like cyberpunk have like a
really uh yeah extensive expensive yeah
they're pioneering the genres
i can't get their hairstyles right
i did not worry about that okay about
that
any other suggestions as far as the
studio for the from the ladies in the
realm before we move on from this topic
all right it looks like we're good so
i'll continue we got together stitch
remember for 29 months thank you sir i
need my ladies to stop playing this
wacko ring game so we can get back to
playing real games he says gang bang
okay
bang bang or gang bang bang probably
bang bang bang bang bang
i'm sorry i'm gonna finish today and
i'll be ready next week okay this is
what they say elder rings says something
else
shout out to mega chard in the chat i
see you blessings there we go
what's the dude good no no taco ten
dollar super chat platinum only does bad
with a bad budget we're not gonna act
like platinum don't got bayonetta one
two near automata and replicant metal
gear rising and astral chain under their
belt as i said the a team there is a b
team
like all the food was burnt stop it it's
like i said we don't know
you know i'm i'm the first person out
there and you know take jabs up like
we really realistically don't know what
a stable platinum is like we like if you
give them stable budgeting and they
don't have to make a game for actually
specifics in the contract
and make avatars and stuff like that
like and they can only focus on the ones
that their their core studio likes then
you know you can see i just personally
don't like the combat style that they
have like i don't like those slash and
hacking kind of games but you know a lot
of people like that stuff okay
like elderly has depth in it and i just
i've never felt like their games have
depth of me
would pass me my sword
let's move on
jd gamer i think this should be the last
one uh 20 of the chat by the way i want
xbox to crush the fighting game scene i
want playstation fans saying that we
almost had that i want microsoft to
acquire wb and capcom and then money hat
texan texas texan tekken dead alive and
king of fighters and start their own
fighting game esports league okay jd
gamer always always objective
completely
objective let's get into these topics we
got to get going so look y'all halo tv
series premiered
salute also want to give a shout out uh
viewership record for power about plus
you know what i'm saying so according to
they've set a new record as a services
most watched series premiere globally in
its first 24 hours of release the
numbers weren't out completely just yet
but they said they also drew um
a plus plus 4.9 million viewers at a
potential linear airing behind
yellowstone on paramount network so it
looks like it's getting off to a great
start it debuted march 24th i got a
chance to go check it out with a salute
microsoft and got a chance to go with
screening shot to kaibatsu pulled up
with me so i have thoughts but it's not
about me right now it's about the uh
ladies of the realm and the opinions and
the hot taking actually this is actually
i believe it's your topic right
and this is your type of if i'm a
mistake or it's my time i forgot now but
anyway i said it all so look i think it
was yours it was right okay cool so look
at the other day it's
it's been numbers are well right there
is some controversy with some but i want
to get the feeling from the ladies in
the realm um where are you at with the
halo series for those who have watched
are we doing like spoiler freedom i i've
watched a week in spoiler but i don't
know who let's just say who has not
watched for the panel
anybody has anybody not watched so okay
we spoil it free for them so everybody
everybody in the chat in the chat
spoilers spoiler time so this is the
moment you walk away from the television
all right you know close your ear
yeah we'll tell you when to come back
yeah
so much stuff happened in this like you
can't realistically talk about the show
without spoiling it it's hard yeah it's
hard it's hard exactly so look again for
those for those who don't want it
spoiled yeah
once the uh tile changes from red off
the topic yeah just look when the tile
changes off of the thing off of this or
when it's on here and then you know
we'll be done with it on your watch all
right no doubt let's set it off
i want to hear what elba got to say
so um i enjoyed the story if you are
looking for um straight
halo what we've seen so far from the
games books and things like that
you are in the wrong place
if you're okay and open to seeing a new
take on halo it's not like completely
you know
different but you're just not gonna have
a one for one is what i'm saying okay
and if you're okay with that then you're
gonna enjoy it
um
i will say he's not the mandalorian
[Laughter]
also
for the budget that they have
i would expect better cgi um
where i was just like that killed me
rough
yeah um and they're supposed to be like
same as game of thrones i want to say
like 10 million episode or something
like that
so i would expect more and i'm hoping
that maybe that gets better um
my last point which i said on our show
um you can kind of tell that the person
who's playing master chief that it's a
little clunky as far as like everything
that's on him
so hopefully they work that out as the
show goes on
maybe they find that things need to be
working a little smoother for him
but yeah other than that it has some
great moments um definitely has tons of
potential
and i want to see how the story unfolds
no doubt let's get delilah hd i am very
curious what are your thoughts girl halo
yeah um
for me i like where this the show jumped
off with the action and i like where
they tried to frame the characters you
know started with the whole uh conflict
between the you know the uh
basically the unsc and the the um human
factions and whatever i thought that was
really good i love the framing
um the characters the acting was decent
um i do agree with boogie that a lot of
parts of it was clunky you can easily
see where they kind of tried to like cut
corners on some parts and then
it's interesting because on the unsc
ship like it was very very polished yeah
on when you're on the planet it wasn't
as polished i'm like okay well we see
where the budget went mm-hmm um
some things in the show also pulled me
out of it and um but yeah i want people
to notice that part for themselves
because some people didn't notice it i
did
um
but yeah and as far as the story i do
it's like a prequel you know and i do
love that way they're playing up the
insurrection part
um
i love it i just think this the way that
they're doing the story is different i
appreciate that i appreciate it it's
different i don't really want to
re-watch the games
like i kind of know what happens in
those games i'm a big halo fan so i know
what's going on and for me it's it's
like i appreciate this this is a
different story and we do it all the
time in movies we do it all the time and
tv so this is to me this is this is fine
no doubt like charisse i am curious what
are your thoughts specifically also the
writing i'm curious about you thought
today um as
uh somebody who has played the games and
read the majority of the books
and the comics
um i am
so far i am enjoying it um a lot of
people have to they they're again mad
because it's not one-on-one with the
movies or i mean the video games but you
have to realize this is his own universe
so you have to
watch it look at it like that so they're
creating their own myths their own lore
with the games as the background
um
so if you look at it like that you will
enjoy it much more um that's look at it
like that but um
i am liking it i do enjoy um the cgi
needs a little bit work because some
when they were talking about mercy and
it was the covenant and all that i was
like
[Laughter]
why you got that face
i was like
like i knew if i hadn't played the games
i wouldn't know exactly who those
characters were i got a chance yeah so
i'm gonna need them to like just fluff
that out a little bit more um the suits
looking nice that was popping i'm loving
that diversity in the show super team um
yes silver team is nice um
i'm loving katherine
um she's
i like her um the writing is it's good
it's solid like it's not bad there's i'm
not seeing anything bad on it i want to
see more episodes i hate the um netflix
has spoiled me i'm sorry
all one day
um so i would have loved to have watched
like maybe two or three episodes to get
a real good feel of the show yes um
but so far
i'm liking this if all the thing that
would have made this better if they had
a glass the planet and i'd have been
like 10 10.
um
like that would have made it better for
me but other than that i'm hey i'm here
obviously i love mysteries is like you
know if they had just come into genocide
yeah just just blow it just kidding
for the most part when they come in the
glass or something usually they've
already won they collapsed oh i'm just
she just said okay she just went to
genocide they're all okay
the hunter the hunter
species they were losing that war and
they're like look if you don't surrender
we're gonna blow up your whole planet
doubt no doubt
lady infamous i am curious what did you
think
oh she's sad oh pause it oh she put the
thoughts together oh wait yeah
um
it's okay
let's get in
i'm gonna have to go with l boogie on
this one the cgi really threw me away
from the immersion of the show and it's
i didn't like it um don't get me wrong i
love the
the costume designs i love the the
acting is okay
um
the diversity is important as well i
just think that if you're gonna make a
show that's gonna be space-based either
if you're gonna either tighten up on the
cgi's or make practical effects for the
show
and
it will make just a little more just a
little more polish just a little more
polished um
i'm just i don't want to
i heard the word mid it is not me okay
okay
not every there's going to be a few
people that's going to be like they want
straight lord directly from haley from
the halo games and the comic books and
stuff like that and i'm not the biggest
halo fan but i know what i saw was not
the same right from what i played in the
video games so if you're really uh just
a fan of like
space just i mean take being a halo fan
out of it and just look at it for what
it really is it's just a good show with
a lot of points that
a lot of references to somebody that we
like and
i will
i'm going to be with your reach i'm
going to wait to
you know
stack the episodes so i can binge watch
them because i i can't be waiting weekly
i know you're here
i can't believe this i'll feel you
one thing i want to mention though was
the sound like i like how they tried to
put in a lot of the games yeah that was
nice it was a nice touch yeah it's a
little first-person view sometimes too
yeah yeah ton of audio cues yes yes
right with the shield with the shield i
didn't hit me
i'm like okay
some people you know i don't know you
have those folks who are
watching the show to hope it fails and
you have people who are watching the
show
and no matter
the problems it's a good show right so
you got to celebrate those two opinions
and um
like i still think that there's tons of
potential for the show but uh
if you watch the show
um
even if you can forgive most of the cg
the cg when they're busting through the
gate
that's all i gotta say all right fair
not fair enough spring it was a shaky
door they had to shake your door in the
in the [ __ ]
yeah because i'm like yo i've seen star
trek discovery i know what paramount
plus can be doing
right
so you're doing a game production team
so it's like what's going on
i thought i agree i think it's a lot of
the unsc though i felt the budget was
there like in their realm like hey they
had all the money it was lit but i feel
with yourself
let's get the lawyers because i have i
got an attic i know we got to set this
off
so addict i saw you had a video out
talking about your thoughts
you know you know what you know it's
funny let's get it since i made that
video
it's
i i've rewatched it in
now you have more of a sour taste of
mine
let's get it
okay
i know somebody on the panel wasn't
going like it i'm ready let's go
there's a difference between
having an annotation or inspiration from
a show and respecting the audience of
that
art and then not respecting it
my brother and me were watching it and
when the human and the covenant was up
there that dude paused the video
and looked at me
and said
really
like it for instance
madness about lady gaga junior
oh yeah go ahead lady gaga stop stupid
this don't feel like master chief he's
sitting there cracking jokes like master
chief is supposed to be a soldier yeah
that's a boat sandwich line yeah and
literally they're they're describing him
as a rebel like he he's going against
the unsc
and it's just like he's taking his mask
off like i don't understand like it just
infuriates him is he not allowed to take
his mask no he's not a mandalorian so he
can yeah where is he says he cannot take
his helmet off right
you can feel like you're in that suit
that's why this is the way
ladies and gentlemen we've
for the past couple games they have been
trying to make him more emotional make
him more of a human they're trying to
open them up like i'm sorry if they're
sitting there
like
i think it was halo 4. they took like
half this mask off where it was like
this much was showing they themselves
have been teasing us with this man's
face
and you needed to tell me that another
form
of all of of media gets it before we do
like technically if you'd have read the
comics you'd already see parts of his
face oh my god
and
they showed him as a kid too but that's
besides the point no it's not because
they have not gained the games you're
literally in the middle of action so how
are you going to take your helmet off of
action so explain to me why he cracking
jokes
master chief is supposed to be supposed
to be and it is not the show is
apparently the show
this watch show has has a different
interpretation of master chief i i can i
can definitely agree with you on that
one you think you're it's just not it
seems like you don't it ain't your cup
of tea
this no apparently it's not a lot of
people's company are you gonna watch
what i'm talking about
huh
are you gonna watch the second episode
i'm gonna i'm going to keep watching it
just to see if it goes okay that's it
she said that's true if you don't like
it it's so hard to pull up hold up if i
would have said no
then you're going to say why does it
bother you then
[Music]
it is a difference between
making something from
and it literally says at the end in the
credits inspired by the video game
phrase
inspiration
and copying verbatim
yeah
you know i don't even mind that they
gave certain people kids that they i
don't even mind that i don't mind if
they like it
to me it's like the the core audience
we literally had a bunch of people upset
because you couldn't place halo for an
entire game as master
they're not going to like me in a second
they're not going to like me diva though
don't worry
don't worry i got you i'm going i got to
wait my turn
regardless how it is man it's just like
look like
it would be different if it was just the
mask taking off it would be different
with just the covenant human that we've
never even seen right what's the main
issue
it would be different if it was just the
master chief cracking jokes that he
never cracks like it would be different
if it was just the cgi but it's all of
these that make it the back show it's
not one of these
there's a combination of things okay
okay okay that's okay
i can i'll wear if i had a mask that had
a target on my head i would because like
sure they could stay this show can end
up being good but it's just like to me
for instance we have a friend that used
to work at 343. he said i liked the
first episode but it did not feel like a
halo show
okay they're they to me they're using
the halo show to sell a subscription
service and don't give and don't care
about the fans that originated from that
it's another perfect example is a show
called death note that they made it into
a movie
and they butchered
light's entire character personality and
it wasn't even light this was not master
chief
this is the way he's been portrayed this
entire time like this was not him it it
to me people said it's just a game what
do you mean it's just a game that's what
we've been playing it's the game mm-hmm
i see where you go listen man it's your
opinion man i respect it let's get
solved because soft seems to be clearly
on the other side soft what's up
i am you know you know me i am of the
mind that blow it up oh yeah yeah
you want the fresh you don't want the
one to one cannon stuff no i mean what
is the point it's a different medium
and tell a different story why would i
want to see verbatim what i've played
elsewhere right it just wouldn't fit
they have to make certain changes for it
to work for tv like the argument can be
made that it shouldn't have been done
anyway i get that argument too there's
some people like just leave it alone
don't do that i would have preferred
that direction right
you give me this
i prefer you just nuke the whole project
okay
you mentioned that uh somebody had a kid
which one were you referring to
it was uh halsey it was palsy i was in
captain keith's daughter and captain
keys yeah
good thing
but see something like that though i
understand why in a show you have to
take those characters and make those
connections because you want people to
care about these characters you want
them to have some sort of intrinsic sort
of connection to one another so that it
matters within the scope of the show
right it makes sense to
isn't that normal that that's not
foreign that's from 2000 what 2011 them
having a daughter
like that isn't that canon that's canon
is it canon it's kim they're saying this
i just want to point out that mariah
i don't get why people complain about
that when that's canon i'm like okay so
then i'm lost on that one looks they
have a daughter that's her
okay
so they just i just wanna i'm a
librarian
like this is what i do like if you need
links i will send them to you okay she's
in that show
oh she's in the game she is in the books
she is there so yeah the chat agrees the
chat agrees because i don't know nothing
about hillary clinton
i know she's in the games but i didn't i
honestly i did not know that miranda
keyes was halsey's daughter she's uh
it's not explicit
he's in rosie that's her that's here
so i guess
it is one of those things where i guess
for somebody who's not into the canon
like that just plays the games not
really pay attention to the backstory
story like
that was no no no for me like clearly we
clearly wasn't paying attention because
they got the receipt
gwg got to the seats
i'm like no no i'm like yeah miranda
keys is like captain keys daughter and i
didn't know i did not know the halsey
connection so beautiful
that said okay so that that's part of it
that's canon as part of the game for me
i i
took this show on its own terms i knew
it was gonna be different and i you know
i didn't see anything that i felt was
egregious really man like
i understand that you have to make chief
a character i understand that you have
to make him personable and likable you
have to make him a human being right
he cannot be this avatar that is just in
the helmet all the time you know even
with mandalorian you had to do it at
some point you had to do it at some
point that's a whole different subject
don't do that
i think about the cook i'm thinking
about that
i can't understand what he did he kicked
and he screamed on that set all the time
to get his face out and i just said
replace the actor i said that a long
time ago for me i did not wait
wait wait
i want to see the i want to see the
receipts all right pedro
this ain't about mandalorian i got you
and that was the wrong dude to use
because i have a whole thing but if he
was watching um uh dcx you would have
been nobody
thought about the promo pro thing where
mandalorian was going but all right here
this is for you sir you've
continue continue
anyway yes anyway so i understand the
need to take off his mask especially in
that particular situation where really
you know he needs this person to trust
him right he needs this person to trust
him all she sees is is these killing
machines right
so um
i agree when it comes to the cgi i think
it's really hard to do cgi on top of
real environments
like the ladies were saying inside the
ships it looked a lot better
but when you're outside in real world
environments and all of a sudden you see
an elite running around he looks like oh
he just drew him there like you know
it doesn't look quite right but i don't
know like
there are plenty of shows that do it
well
yeah right there was like a shine and a
sheen to the to like the at least
unreal engine 3
i'm like
so i definitely yeah i definitely need
to see that improve but i i you know i
like i like what i saw so far i want to
see where it goes
i'm not offended by it like some people
are offended by it i'm just like i went
in knowing it was going to be different
i went in knowing that they were trying
to make a show that appeals to more
people than just halo fans i don't know
if they necessarily did they necessarily
succeeded at that or will succeeded that
but
i you know i didn't see bad acting
necessarily i've seen far worse shows
than this
and when it comes to sci-fi sci-fi stuff
on tv is very hit or miss right yeah it
could lean all the way into the cheesy
or it could be great and i think the
fact that it's a we let's be thankful
it's not a movie because a movie we get
one shot right
they get it wrong they get it right
either way we're not getting a complete
picture of what these characters can be
for me
what i want to see
i hope they don't
they don't attack the essence of what
the characters are right you can change
the stories around them right
but for me i i think the essence of the
characters are still is still intact
that's why for me it still feels like
halo
um i think in the long term master chief
is this dude like he is a dude that
he he realized that hey
the fight's over here hey
i need these people to start trusting me
after i've obliterated them and murdered
them for i know how many years leading
up to this so i think the core of master
chief the hero is still there and i
think the core of halsey
of keys all of that stuff still feels
like it's there if they start changing
that yeah then i would have more of a
problem with it i don't have to disagree
with the master chief part that's
something you know i get it i agree i
get it everyone else feels dirty to the
core but it's just master chiefs that's
my whole argument it's just how they
treat the master chief in it
and one thing that i would have
preferred is that the fact that
they were they were kind of secretly
fighting the covenant all this time
while they're still fighting the the
insurrectionist
that was weird because i was like why
didn't they just start further back i
would have preferred
that they show if you want to give a
huge character arc to master chief
becoming this hero right show him when
he's murdering innocent people right and
then
all of a sudden the covenant
i know but like if you want to see him
become a hero
and still have to deal with the things
that he's done in his past right
show
they alluded to it right they alluded to
it
but now for me i would have preferred to
see that ark because then at the same
time i would have loved to have seen how
the unsc reacts to a surprise invasion
from from the covenant as opposed like
who the hell are these people as opposed
to we already know we're fighting them
secretly but we're still fighting
against the instrument
yeah so i'm just like because it's like
in the beginning though yeah but that's
weird because it's like paying attention
to the tv before the dude cut it off
they was explaining to you that they
were helping out because of stuff that
was going on but that's correct i'm
sorry no no but but this is the thing
right if you like if you really need
these people on your side and to help
right
why are you still
having why are you still attacking human
beings when you know you need them on
your side and then that that the captain
or the general the who was giving halls
the other orders right she said it yeah
we've been fighting these people for
years and we still don't know what they
want i'm like for years why you been
fighting for yet it's just weird that
all of a sudden now years into the fight
is when you have no choice but to but to
rescue the insurrectionist now and like
it's just very weird the way they set
that up where i would prefer like
everybody's oblivious to the covenant
the covenant arriving everybody's like
oh man we have to work together now so
that's it i would have liked to see that
but beyond that again i didn't see
anything egregious i'm excited to see
where it goes
and it could go left
or it could you know it could be
good i have not talked to you about this
i need to know where do you feel about
healing so um addict calls me and i'm
working and um
addicts going in because he first you
know
he sends me the the thumbnail
and he's like yo check that out tell me
what you think of it i'm about to post
it so i look at it and he goes hold on i
got another one i said don't please
don't do the ocd thing with me trying to
figure out some spoil my like new thing
and he's like no no no you know what i'm
gonna go with this one i'm like all
right cool
and then he goes he starts to go on on
the show i told him he didn't see it yet
he said yeah man and then master chief
helmet comes off i said what the hell
[Laughter]
you didn't hear this was gonna happen
though okay so first of all they did say
it was going to happen
first first and foremost i go in uh uh
desensitizing tank when it comes to
anything that yeah you do that you stay
away from any news or something i don't
want to hear you think i don't want to
see anything you know i'm not these
dudes that look to do reviews i don't
want to play demos i don't want to do
none of that stuff give me the finished
product when you got it and don't talk
to me about it that part yeah you've
always been positive this is my guy so i
didn't go in on him i just laughed and
he laughed and he was like oh my bad
and i was like damn i was doing really
good ducking and dodging right it's okay
i got home that afternoon i said i got
to see it now
because i know a million other people is
going to hit me up with what's going on
put it on
i'm a fan of d space nine i'm a fan of
every star track i'm a fan of star wars
i'm a fan of lost in space i'm a fan of
all type i'm picard i'm a fan of all of
that stuff and you guys are right uh
paramount has definitely shown different
uh series that had better effects
all right and when they did bring back
certain things
they also know
star trek fans ain't taking none of that
bs
right so if you don't do it right star
fa star track fans will shut your
streaming system down
they don't have that same opinion about
this unproven franchise as the first
time that it's coming up and don't have
the lineage of a star track
we have halo
everybody else is talking about video
games this is a different interpretation
upon this thing they have other mediums
as far as books and comic books uh you
know novels and comic books this is the
first time that it's in a
series format it's supposed to be a
movie and it was uh you know little
snippets tv shows that we watched the
cartoon stuff
and this is serious
when it i wasn't appalled by the cgi
i wasn't appalled by some of the bad
acting okay i wasn't even appalled by
his helmet coming off
i wasn't appalled by
too much of nothing because what they
did was they kept some of the essence
when he got shot up and he leaned behind
the wall and i and then i heard the
audio cue with his shield coming up
it told the audience
he's not invulnerable right right and we
understood now that the covenant has the
same type of technology with their
shields and if you keep shooting it it
will dissipate and then you're able to
shoot them
okay
what what took me
was i knew this wasn't a disney
production
when it was killing women and children
oh they straight wholesale yeah yeah it
was
myrtle's going not playing like he shot
the lady leg off and she flipped in
there and he shot her in the body i said
i'm all in on this right here i got
absolutely
yes yeah what's wrong with it
so they did the edibles and they
tripping in the field like oh
she like yo up there is some stuff we
got to get up out of here they doing
some stuff so the edible dude was like
man shut up let me go check it out and
they blew him up
this is the worst way to die hi
i'm like yo i said this this ain't got
no chill at all
first of all these are teenagers
somebody's supposed to get away they all
supposed to get away technically right
in the disney film i'm used to disney
stuff this ain't disney here
so the one girl makes it back
and it gets she gets back there
and the town is in disbelief of what's
going on but she shot her flesh she did
what she's supposed to do she's trained
by her pops really well
the level of brutality that's inside
this series
is
kind of second to none when it comes to
a video game like you're getting what
you can do in the video game i'll give
you that like when they when they're
using the energy blade it's doing it
what it is
somebody got that yeah
the brutality was so bad
that when they got that door open with
all those kids and women in it i thought
it was i was convinced it was about to
show that yeah i was like they gonna
really do that part two
and i thought that was gonna save them i
thought it was gonna be something i
thought at the end
the one problem i did have let's get it
after they already said that yo we gonna
kill her
you know they're gonna suck the oxygen
yeah just talk about okay let me hear
where you
article 72 or whatever it was this is
millionaires
you you sat there and said
i can pull this
how about i tell this type of story yeah
okay that's how you want to play it see
nobody everybody thinks is one and two
options
either you're gonna let me go on but
tell the story you won't tell me no the
option is i'm gonna kill you that's
another
and you know when that came down that's
cool but master chief saving it what i
didn't like it just get it
her face was bloody he didn't even wipe
her face off
you've been touched by this thing she's
walking around with this fake blood on
her face for at least longer than
supposed to right
i mean nobody washed her face nothing
even when she did clean up a little bit
she said they eat it
nothing so that's the only that's
the thing oh god
everything else
[Laughter]
but it's dope though now when they took
his head off
the helmet off and and
i saw that it was the dude
i saw who it was that was master chief
the the lucky leprechaun dude oh man
yeah you know who he is uh if you see
american gods head of origins
i said man i was disappointed i was
disappointed i i thought i was going to
get you know
i might be your new wolverine too you
know oh who him
he too tall king don't like that i'm
gonna throw you away yeah king don't
like tall wolverine
anyway but it's it's though it's a good
take on it i don't care about the the
video games yeah uh extending if i want
video game stuff i play the video games
if i want the novel stuff gonna read the
novels i want the comic books
this is a different take it's fun
it's
deep space nine with my halo dudes
so when i saw elites and i can't wait to
see brutes and different type of grunts
i'm to see different aspects of stuff i
want to see the halo ring okay so
anybody really pissed off with it is
because you had expectations for it
this is not your expectations if you
have those same expectations go play the
games where you feel safe at but this is
a different place that they're trying to
build on this is not the same stuff and
yes they did build on some of the law
it's inspired by
it's not verbatim
all right
is king you get upset over the little
stuff of marvel changes
but but but i can't get upset about it
listen i i said that's your opinion i
have no problem with it when they do
something weird in a marvel thing
yeah
i have to live with it but i go right
back to my safe comic books where i'm
safe at you've
been about the height difference with
wolverine for years oh okay well first
of all
i don't like hugh jackman you don't like
you
so for the same reasons
that you know he brought up that man
delorean stuff she was the reason why i
never got wolverine in the costume
i would have shut up had he put that
mask on and played his part but that's
the interpretation kid you know like the
interpretation is the booster
but that's what they want to do if you
if you like it
you're supposed to stay in the only
tell him who's he gonna tell i'm not
putting the mask on king when he started
that role the best part about that
original that gave him too much hype
i just got one thing to say to you king
if you want that that accurate wolverine
this comic book
stuff i know i do i do i don't watch
those movies i only watch the one where
he dies
let me jump in cause we go look when he
died
[Laughter]
put that x on his tombstone it was over
it's funny when we're passionate about
something that we love look you know
that's how i feel about it and i got a
confession first because i didn't
realize thank god i watched this thing
twice because i didn't realize
what i saw at i'm two episodes in
yeah so i've already watched the second
one ahead i'm not going to spell that
for you guys but
now that i re-watch it i'm like wait a
minute there's more than they got to do
right because i was upset when i left
right my feeling was
it's good
it's a different take i have no problem
first caveats
i have no problem with artistic
direction and not telling the canon
story i never have a problem if you want
to tell a unique story
all good that's not my issue i didn't
even have a problem coming in i already
knew the mass was going to come off
right didn't have a problem with that
you know my whole thing was from where
you guys seen it which is episode one i
understand why i feel that way i'm like
okay i get it because it ended i'm
assuming let me keep correct once you
touch the object in the ship right then
flies off that's where y'all ended that
right correct yeah okay
from that point on
which y'all have not seen is my biggest
frustration right i'm not gonna spoil it
y'all will get to that on thursday right
now back to this episode which the
issues i have which is why i'm gonna
more align myself with adequate one
thing
all right
i understand first let me tell you what
i like i'm i'm not like a huge
production guy like i'm the guy i don't
go to i'm not the guy that's like you
know the cg is bad i don't i can't
discern high quality movie stuff that's
just not my back so i thought from a
gamer standpoint no look good i'm cool
the leafs look like the elites little
halo sounds you know what i'm saying i
even like the unsc you know who i like
besides holly i love the actress choice
for her
i like the um
the the indian actress that we like get
your spartan undercut the boss what you
need yeah i love her she'll be like
she'll be like it's a spartan giving the
uh a refugee a weapon what is wrong with
you i love everything she about like her
cold-heartedness i'm about her
i love the choices i mean um the younger
keys i felt she's a little shaky i was
like yeah i felt like she just wasn't
sure and confident and stuff like that
okay i see where they're going with
homegirl that survived from the rebel
camp she seemed to be more of a focus
yeah i know you don't like the blood of
the face
but you know i did like the elites
because i felt no disrespect to the
grunts
them as a covenant brings more fear of a
threat yo here come the elites y'all and
then you see the classic energy play you
see them doing the invisible you see i
even like when he escaped he jumped into
the bed she asked all right all right
like it got off running for me when he
came down they flew down i was like okay
i'm in trust me i was not upset where it
went left is where i gotta co-sign at it
i'm not mad that the mask is coming off
what pissed me off is she is no threat
to him in my opinion
what are you taking your mask off for
her he literally said your gun ain't
gonna do nothing to this armor you know
that
like he literally said like there's
nothing you gonna do you gonna listen or
what because i got article article 72 to
get you out of here if i choose so i
just felt like
i knew the math was gonna come more i
just yeah i just felt it was making a
point like if you're gonna kill me you
gotta you gotta shoot here shoot
situation i felt like
it wasn't all on the line that he had to
to do that at that point i'm okay with a
couple i just felt that she didn't earn
it okay
go ahead guys
so
let's say you are your master chief
right you've been the perfect soldier
all this time you know who you are yes
right
then you touch this artifact right yep
you go now you don't know who you are
okay yep malfunction you're going with
the malfunction route right no yeah
he was he was literally being
non-compliant right he was being no i
get that i get that
i'm just saying from a show runner
standpoint this is where i agree with at
it i understand that they're gonna do
different but we have to be real even
though yes there's been glimpses in halo
4 there's glimpses in comic books here
and there that the masks come up stuff
like that i just felt like in episode
one they being real blatant that we
doing what we want to do with this we
don't care about you
this is awesome what you saying what you
said is you needed some extra grease
then yeah
just give me jimmy give me your paws
look at it from like the mandalorian
kind of similar thing someone that
normally is always masked and then he
gets unmasked like they it built up it
was a moment
no threat like that to be like
okay fine malfunction okay fine
where they lost
when they lost me
is that was pablo schreiber right with
his face out okay cool
but like never puts his mask back on
is is is
he talking
about the [ __ ] he doesn't feel the need
to put his ass you know where he got me
like putting his face out though no all
right you know i don't like that but
fine fine fine i know it's coming up
fine all i'm saying is at that little
combat evolved where then he's in the
chevy texas that's fine that's fine
that's fine where i lost me
is
i like how he presented himself stoic
you know emotional like he's he wants to
talk all the time now get the panel do
this do that like
like to give him orders
to that to that space though
and
the malfunction part that you laughing
at it's just he he the barriers that
were put into place because when they
did show his body scan on the table yeah
all the synapses was firing yeah so and
it went straight to his brain where now
all the inhibitors that they did have in
place to force him to comply because
that's why the the the captain was
looking like yo you got a spartan that's
acting up right this dude literally can
take down everybody that's here right
and if he has his team
it's really a rap so the fact that he's
independent in thought in his body his
mind now is overriding everything that's
put into place i can get that part i
understood that part i'm just like one
part you just brought back up though was
when
all of them dudes is outside before he
grabs the the um the stone the artifact
he's still talking with his face yeah
i'm like don't worry
i mean just like just shut up like
you're talking too much that's all i'm
saying like bro you talking way too much
you would you could still
be malfunctioning but it's like now
you're having all these conversations
and it just disconnected me i would just
be honest like
all right you might want to not watch
because i'm pretty i know oh yeah
oh
yeah as as episode 2 showed me
where this is going and i'm like oh
now like i said there's going to be a
it's going to be contentious there's
going to be a hardcore
community right that's gonna say oh hell
no right okay i have a question
i have a question yes yes um so what did
y'all expect him not to speak for the
entire season no not that not that i
know you guys haven't what i'm lying
every couple of minutes
what i'm saying he's a very stoic
character right he's a very it's for a
video game i get it but
hold on prior to this mask coming up
pablo schreiber
was very
minimal with conversation
i felt after that he became a chatterbox
as soon as the mask came off he wants to
talk about things it's like they were
trying to build up okay this is the
master chief you like and then the
moment it came off
yeah it is like to me it's pablo how
much did he really say though
he gave her instructions
you know two actors inside a room one
can't be a mute and the other one
talking
okay
yes lock all them have their helmet off
it's a common thing it's just the fact
that you're playing as master chief is
the reason why you think it's helmeted
no i'm not mad at the hell no i don't
know
i just want to say that for people who
okay the helmet ain't really the issue i
just want him to to still maintain a lot
of his personality but they they're
going with this object clearly has
changed him and that's where they're
going with it well it has released him
because before then the reason why he
was so stoic is because he was being uh
yeah i know where they're going with it
i i just said that i can't wait till
they put katana in his head yeah shut
him back there shut up
i just
always said this is down a little bit
that's all i'm talking about
but for overall as the first episode i
thought overall the first episode was
solid and i didn't have too much problem
aside from
the way his behavior was afterwards and
that's just my personal choice that's
all you feel like he changed what he
said yeah i felt like it was pablo
[Laughter]
and it would it would have bothered me
if i hadn't thought about the whole
artifact changing him right if it was
just like him like oh all of a sudden
now i have a i have a heart and i have
you know then it would be weird get that
episode sir what do you get oh yeah i
know the thing
is though is regardless how it is me
personally like
regardless if you feel like this can't
do this in a tv format that can't do
that in a tv format they took a gaming
format and they took a character that
has a a definite personality and i'm
sorry they changed it like look if you
guys could say it's for the better of
the show and that that's debatable we
have to see it we we've only seen one
episode but at the end of the day it's
like
i'm confident that if you took other
incidences and people on this panel's
favorite franchise and you changed stuff
people would feel it's like king
king says i don't have a problem with
this it's fine but you change
wolverine's height and oh my god it's
it's the end of the world it's like
we can all with the [ __ ] thing is
when i first saw this
i was i was like wow like and i wasn't
even caring about the the mask coming
off i'm more upset over the mask coming
off thing as like like a gaming watch
you know we've waited years for the
gaming
shoe to fall down and people could say
oh it came out this it came out on that
that's that's subjective it's just like
they have never openly
showed his face
they've always done it where they just
see a part of it like i felt like that
should have been reserved for the you
felt they took that from the game i
played the games for years
and the games aren't gonna watch the
show is what you're saying
well i mean
i never
[Laughter]
it's just we gotta agree to disagree but
listen yeah we gotta see how i was gonna
go i don't think necessarily all gonna
doom but we gotta see where they go you
know say i'm curious once y'all watch
episode 2 how y'all feel we revisit but
that's
what y'all like it unless anybody else
got any additional thoughts on it let's
move on so you're going to get the json
we good
yeah we got a couple okay uh we got
actually we got boom team two dollars if
we chat enough respect ilp gwg pick up
yourself
let's go
and we got jd gamer five dollars to be
chat much respect to grg gwg not gig but
i guess grg as well
i know about that knowledge that's the
origin exactly i know about that
knowledge you bring you've been go i've
been ghost watching ever since your tick
days
and we got raiden blade two pound super
chat i'm in the uk so i can't watch it
anyway pistol i was talking about the
show i guess that it's not available
there yet
there are ways around that
allegedly
then we got trey bone 408
two dollar super chat spring cleaning
time need a p and i need a ps5 to
collect the dust
chevy's gotcha
17 five pound super chat as much as we
love halo fans need to understand that
halo doesn't have good dramatic writing
got to give the covenant back their bomb
what was that yeah
that's another thing
about that super life i'm telling you
that's another thing sometimes people i
mean i love halo but halo is not citizen
kane
necromancers ale 10 super chat for me i
was wanting the first halo game 117
sergeant johnson the covenant the first
contact with the flood there we go you
would have captured so many more people
with that then expand the halo universe
yeah sure so master keith the murderer
you are ridiculous move it on oh since i
got this
yeah go ahead
like look like i would have preferred
a show where sergeant johnson was the
main character and showing how he's
going through the first parts of things
like look that's my that's my issue it's
like
they have all this more on halo did you
really think that we're going to make a
show without master chief at the at the
front of it though
like yeah
i think that there's a chance it's not
going to go but good writing
and a good show in general people are
going to watch regardless true true
that's true
um lucious augustus five dollars yeah go
ahead
well i was just going to say that
my only gripe was the whole human with
the covenant oh we need to touch that
yeah
i want to see what that is about yeah
that was like that that was interesting
yeah
then we got lucius augustus 5.00 chief
has been cracking jokes since the first
game his jokes are dry he made jokes
since halo combat evolved
get your nut and bolt sandwich
then we got makai 28 ten dollars which
that addict is right you don't show
master chief's face it's sacred it's
like unmasking batman batman been on
master millions
are ridiculous
it's like unmasking spider-man when he
pulls off his mask every every movie
all right we got big clown gaming five
dollars
salute to the fam thank you
see the big things congratulations on
the ign situation i see you brother
doing big things sir and we got spartan
ghost once again five pounds super chat
sorry addict i disagree steven seagal
one-liner master chief doesn't work in
2022.
also death note movie was trash not the
case for halo though and again it goes
back to the thing about movies like with
a movie
it's hit or miss and then a lot of times
you're going to miss because we we did
see
well master chief was in halo
of
the fall of reach right like 30 40
minutes and he did a good job in that
like i get inside tv show it's not the
same thing but it's just like look like
like to me it's like i i didn't care if
it like
if they could have went this direction
then it would have made sense if they
built up to it if and slowly he started
opening up to this girl and so slowly he
started getting to that point where you
know
he has to do something to gain her trust
but it's just like she she's holding a
gun at him that literally can't do any
damage to him whatsoever
you know what he also just but she also
just said
but again he needs somebody to trust him
that just told him that he murdered her
mother like
it could have been any gesture but that
was the gesture they chose right it
showed my face
because if you have the
he's telling her you can kill me right
now if you want
i'm like but why like you can't do
nothing to me
like like oh no that's we gonna go out
she shot him in the heads
i mean because he took the mask off i'm
like you could literally just tell her
the same thing but hey move it off we're
gonna go too long
and we got matt titch bond ten pound
super chat i've not seen halo yet no
paramount plus in the uk but i'm on
board with everything that sav has said
it doesn't need to be a one-to-one copy
of the games and books and chief needs
to be a well-developed character yeah
that's what they're going for we know
the direction
we got blaze 4k 10 super chat king you
need to bend the knee dawg
deal is a deal sony is god peace oh my
god i told you he already did he did
that where you were you clearly ain't
been watching because
i told i even told him
to
just because you won't go and look at it
blaze don't mean it didn't happen yeah
here we go when a tree falls in the
forest no one's around it definitely
makes it sound make it sound right it
happened bro we'll get you you need
continue yourself then we got raiden
blade two pounds super chat
king space above and beyond halo better
be better
we'll see we will see
we got donald taco five dollar super
chat don't talk bro i kept saying that
about blood about the blood on her face
what is the issue with the blood i don't
even have that issue
like they like they have
like they have santa wipes you know up
on in the middle
right but then i realized it was more to
show how much the unsc doesn't care
about them that makes sense no doubt
then we got donald taco again five
dollar super chat stop comparing master
chief to the mandalorian the mandalorian
had a plot reason for not taking off his
mask so it was special what is master
chief's reason
if you
if you if you speak to somebody who's a
fan of the games the reason is it's
never been done and it shouldn't be
like
moving so
jonathan b member for two absolutely
master chief buckle up [ __ ] oh my god
again with the monologue shut up
now man oh like
i don't like my bad spit mad bars that's
all continue
you gotta keep in mind he's seen another
episode too yeah oh y'all gonna learn
i'm not gonna say that
yeah we might we might be yeah i want to
remember these takes for next week
we're gonna revisit this at the end
because regardless what you guys seem to
think about me uh i i hyped up kingdom
hearts 3 said it was a horrible game
after it came out i hyped up final
fantasy 15 said it was a horrible game
after i'm not horrible but average like
i will say if i'm wrong or not
both these people on this chat be all
extra i remember you i'll remember you
you
are they gonna have cheap outside of the
armor in episode two oh no that would
kill it for me no comment
wow and then somebody in the chat saying
i hope lock will be in the series oh no
that's good
i didn't mind lock i just felt like they
didn't build him they didn't usually
didn't use it i love it i would love to
see more of them
yep we're counting up okay all right
cool look this is awesome
yeah
so if you're up this is you
yeah
yeah so uh friend of the show jason
schreier uh earlier this week uh
wrote up on bloomberg that uh as early
as this coming week we might get an
actual announcement from playstation
as to the uh
the
what people some people deem to be an ex
a game pass uh competitor there's code
name spartacus sort of um
subscription plan
so uh yeah i guess he has some inside uh
kind of knowledge
that it's coming soon whatever whatever
it's gonna be the announcement is coming
soon and the assumption is that it will
be dropping soon after that announcement
so um
yeah what do you guys think i know we
talked about this when we first heard
the speculation about what it could be
right um
and it's been
there's been kind of a little bit of a
change around what people are expecting
that they probably aren't expecting the
three tiers that we were talking about
before um obviously the talk around it
is is also that it's not going to be
having first party games day and date um
so what do you guys think about this as
as the announcement seems to be eminent
and a lot of the you know the
discussions around it is our what is it
going to be how much is it going to cost
um
and is it going to be worth it in any
way shape or form as a value add for
playstation gamers you know all right
let's get our lady up for this
um i did see
a a photo
yesterday about the quote
yeah i heard that
because whoever did that they didn't
don't know they don't know how to they
don't know
yeah
[Laughter]
that was fake i know that um yeah this
is what the thing is for me i need to
have that
new sony's uh service to have games that
i
want to be able to play on their
platforms um original metal gear i'm
down with that
games games that are like certified
playstation hits that we have that are
generational that should be on the
service just like xbox game pass
um
i think it's going to cost a little bit
more
i think
i don't know it's just it's i feel it in
my good that it's going to
cost a little bit more
um
like i said they got to have games to
entice me to spend more money on another
service especially a game of service
and
i hope they do something with it um the
real fans the real playstation fans
they're gonna go get it they're gonna
they're gonna say oh this is gonna be
better than game pass and
uh things of that sort but i'm going to
let you know that for me personally this
has not been one gaming like
service that has been better than xbox
game pass so
for them
for for sony they're gonna have to
really
you know critique their little packages
to make sure it can be accommodating to
everybody okay for them to be enticing
people to actually use the service okay
so you basically you need to see that
what that value proposition is yes it is
okay yes fair enough fair enough
let's get l bugs l bugs what you think
is playstation spartacus from what you
hear so far
um if it's true and in no tier you get a
dandate it's a no for me you provide no
value
fair enough is it is it more is it more
of the day-to-day aspect or just
what if the price it is out of whack
no it's both because basically why am i
paying for a service when i'm not
getting your first party titles
and you're trying to basically fluff a
reason for me to pay you monthly um yeah
okay okay so el uh do you like is if
they do have a tier with that is does
price become a factor because i mean
price becomes a factor right yeah
because yes ten dollars gets you
everything essentially right right and
they and and i think that's why they
have such a hard way to go right because
game pass has spoiled everyone who has
game pass so now
it's very much
why do i need to add your service
to my long laundry list
of
you know whatever brand plus services
i'm playing for
why do i need to pay for your service
because if it's only old games
no
if it's only demos which why am i paying
for demos don't even list it as a free
option because i shouldn't be paying for
them anyways they're hustling okay okay
right okay yeah that needs to be in your
lowest here now
that's not a wait are you trying to say
i got a premium feature
some free [ __ ] already already
but i like your service i get them
already like why are you listing this
because if you're going to the if you're
going right demos aren't a big thing
anymore right if you're going to the to
the lengths of having essentially all
your games have demos at this point now
right
why not have the most people have access
to that so they can have a better idea
why are you going to charge me whatever
30 a month so i can play a demo maybe
yeah
so if it's just if it's old games and
it's that and it's a ps now type of
thing
i really don't see enough value in that
besides what i'm already paying unless
they plan on taking like if they plan on
stripping some of the stuff from the
other service to get you to buy okay
okay then i could see more you want to
do that but otherwise what i'm already
playing paying for ps uh
what is it the one that make you pay to
pay it please plus yeah ps plus right if
it's
why do i need to pay for this in
addition to that is what my question is
fair enough fair enough that's how you
feel value proposition
let's get uh let's share this
where are you at with this like
playstations
i can't figure out how the nicest way to
say this
and boogie said it for me i ain't
touching this i see nothing of value for
me i that's no reason for me to dust off
my four i see no reason we got five
um
uh if like if it doesn't have day and
day games like i would like to build up
my ps collection because playstation
collection because again i just bought a
system i don't on the game i've beaten
on it is spiderman um
i would like to but
like i see nothing here for me
now you keep it apart
you move on for me
it's not for her
conclusion
[Laughter]
lady delilah i am curious you know talk
about as a potential game pass you know
competitor and we've been hearing it
from
for me they just have to
the value has to be there like i'm not
i'm not seeing anything that appealed to
me right away just based on like the
graphics we've seen on twitter
and whatnot um
because i mean i would love to get like
god of war day and day i would love to
get the next whatever uncharted or
uh
ghosts ushima like i like to get all of
that the end date and so for me that's
what i would like to see all right when
they do it i don't know now that pricing
structure they had on that graphic was a
little little iffy because if you notice
if you read the little fine print say
every three months like sixty dollars
every three months
hopefully hopefully that confirmed
because that would be crazy that's
actually true hopefully it's like
like now don't get it twisted sony has
an amazing library and they got a lot of
people from playstation 3 era pps4 i
mean they got a ton they can pull from
but um
we just have to see what the way to see
you know and i hate playing middle
ground here but i mean i kind of have to
try to yeah
it is it is it kind of is what it is no
doubt we'll see they supposed to be this
week right yeah inbound common it's
common like when shreya and the gang got
like let's see let's see i would love to
revisit this conversation then once yes
let's see what let's see what the tears
are
addict spartacus inbound where you at
oh i got
we've been knowing this we've discussed
it like a billion different ways at the
end of the day we got to see what what
the tiers are like you know remember
when someone leaked the tiers a long
time ago but they didn't we didn't get
prices for them right
i think it was
it was was it jason
jason no not not the the value
proposition but just the value
just that it exists
oh yeah he did talk about potential
tears yeah he did
and if it was his tears
it's it's it's in the bushes man
we we have to see if it's those tears
okay uh you know
and then we gotta talk like you know
they're they're making a lot of games as
a service right now too
you know are they going to be free games
as a service what are you going to put
in this value like are they going to
cost money like are you
like to me
you can have the greatest you can
literally make this five dollars a month
if you don't have nothing that's
consistently going in it right but you
have game pass getting games day and
date and they're actually spending money
to get certain third party that came out
a couple months ago and actual you know
some games come in there day and day
yeah like regardless how you feel about
some of those games some people do play
them you see it on the uh on the most
played list they go up every time you
had gary's in the galaxy came out and i
was like what the third or fourth most
played game on xbox like a couple weeks
after that to happen like
you know
that is a beast to compete with yeah and
i feel like you know people that say oh
sony's not doing this for competitor
sony's been doing everything to try to
compete they lowered the price so i
guess that wasn't for a competitor they
made it to where you can download the
games i guess that wasn't for a
competitor like they've literally done
what microsoft's doing they're mimicking
and they're like picking up the crumbs
of this giant biscuit that microsoft's
been eating down this hallway and so
he's just going behind them and picking
up a chrome like oh download games oh yo
you stupid like
9.99 do it like it's just like look like
people who say this isn't direct
competition for game pass like you're
not paying attention
like they they know that
they're probably not going to do date
game pass but they know that there is a
possibility and a good possibility that
that's the way the industry leads so
they're setting up
this
this this contingency plan where they're
like
if everything goes south and game pass
starts
taking the market from them hit the red
button
put our stuff in that in that service
okay no i see i see where you go i want
to add real quick yeah go for it i'll be
curious to know like
you know you know with with microsoft
and with game pass they also tackle the
pc market i'll be curious to know like
how sony is going to appeal to the pc
market yeah with this subscription model
as well very good point yeah i'll jump
in to kind of uh bookmark everybody what
they were saying i didn't agree with
still so many questions we don't know
the official you know price point tier
structure you know what's actually being
offered i agree with ladies and gentle
if it's just
like the old stuff or it's like you're
trying to re-package
back competition with a price stuff to
the base price to the base package so
they can naturally increase the price of
the overall
aesthetic of it yeah they're like oh
we're going to give you playstation plus
some form of playstation now we're going
to add something else on it but instead
of being 9.99 a month it's going to be
15 a month right i got i got to see that
i'm also curious about two things though
one you know about we we've heard
rumblings about them with like kind of
film stuff or netflix stuff or you know
any type of playstation movie stuff i'm
curious if they try to add some type of
additional value that's not gaming and
then um the other thing i i i'm pretty
sure that my confidence they did say
they're not going to do day and date but
i am curious with their live service
focus lately obviously they got bungee
they've got they make it they clearly
want to make strides in that zone so if
i'm curious if those type of games would
enter a day-and-date scenario because
that to me makes sense for them to kind
of put that in a service like that and i
told people you know when destiny you
know obviously bungie uh was acquired
you know i knew destiny clearly was
gonna have to come out of game pass but
i'm curious if they would utilize like
okay that's the two is in this or some
type of appeal for their live service
stuff would kind of generate engagement
i do agree with attic i think this is
kind of forward thinking from them in a
sense that they
don't want to get left behind if the
industry adapts because microsoft has
been clearly ahead of the game as far as
azure as far as all this stuff so it'll
be interesting i'm curious i'm curious
to see if it lands with their base if
their base
has has no problem with the price point
structures all that stuff so these days
you don't
even attempt to adapt you become the
blockbuster yeah you'll get up out of
here exactly so you know and that's the
argument my counter to kid who keeps
saying oh i don't see that i'm going to
exist anymore or whatever whatever
because if they don't do anything if
they stood pat and everything was status
quo then to me that showed that they're
not trying to evolve but they are at
least trying they may be a little late
and microsoft's ahead and they were they
clearly partnered with them it's not
even just late though they're half-assed
with it yeah but you know what that's
the thing historically i've always felt
they've always dipped one toe in first
right not saying it's great i've i i
agree i feel microsoft's always forward
pushing forward thinking moving it even
sometimes too aggressively to their
fault sometimes right because they see
where the industry's going and sometimes
we are in a digital age right xbox one
did eventually do the things that we do
now right but at the time people weren't
ready for it but i think like sony
sometimes because of their base
they are beholden and i think day and
day is part of it you know because of
their base they it's like babysitting
too much credit i think you give them
too much credit
you like to think that you know they're
you know they're cuddling their fan base
you know they're trying to make it as
least resistant as possible for them i
see it as they want they're very
business oriented and not even now yeah
like
our
more
conscious business they are old money
business
and they want to give you the least and
get the most back okay i see you go
that's where you go
i get that i get that my only counter to
it which is i would agree prior to this
generation i just feel that
with ryan he making moves that i gotta
agree with king that are kind of
complicit
with what how
you know microsoft is moving which is
weird to me you know i'm saying but
historically yes i think you are correct
i think historically you're correct
they've been
more slower like to you they've been
comfortable with the traditional model
the old way of doing things and
you know that's just how it is we gotta
see how it go
that's all i got so
let me let me round out the yeah round
out real quick i didn't we got to move
on after that um let me read to y'all
real quick what the original tiers were
sort of uh sort of speculated to be
well these are the these are the light
ones right so the first one was the ten
dollar tier ps plus essentials was
essentially playstation plus as it is
now right so if you look at playstation
plus now
for a while now they've been doing a
good job of giving certain games day one
in there whether it be buck snacks
whatever the case may be whether it be
um destruction all-stars stuff like that
so they've been kind of dipping their
toe in that with that ten dollars here
right
that's the base tier ps plus now ps plus
extra which was rumored to be the second
tier which is 13 a month would be ps
plus
a playstation 4 library doesn't indicate
how many games right playstation 5
library doesn't indicate how many games
what games or anything like that that
would be their middle tier
the last year the the whatever the
premium tier yeah ps plus premium 16 a
month you get ps plus ps4 library ps5
library the extended demos that boogies
talk about
back compatible library and game
streaming and this extended demos even
mean right that's again why are you
giving me this at my premium tier why do
i need to see this at the premium tier
and then when you when you think about
and this is the thing at 16 a month it's
just a dollar but it still is a dollar
more expensive than xbox's most premium
offering game pass ultimate which gives
you
that the pc market as well right right
yep go ahead go ahead
to be honest with you
ea access does a thing like that like
you get to play like six five hours of a
like the game before it comes out so
maybe that's something like maybe you're
copying that swag like i don't know
to me the thing about this is is that
when you look at that premium tier the
one that's comparable to what i think
many people have in game pass ultimate
which gives you the online stuff and
gives you the pc game pass and console
game pass when you look at this
it doesn't compare we don't know what
we're getting as a ps4 library we don't
know we're getting as a ps5 library when
you talk about the back compat stuff
they're capable at this point of giving
us downloaded versions of ps1 games ps2
even ps3 games i don't want i i'm tired
of the ps3 excuse i know it's been
difficult but the work has been done on
pc do you understand
and as these machines are closer to pc
the work can be done to get it there i
just don't know that they care about
doing that in the same way that
microsoft has done it and then the game
streaming thing again
that puts game streaming in a bad
position on the playstation platform
simply because when you look at it on
microsoft side it's something they're
giving to you as an additive thing right
right
and it's included at every level of
subscription not just the premium one
right so
you know
unless they're saying that this is the
best game streaming service that there
is out there beating out you know
geforce now beating out azure algebra
they're using that this is the thing
this is the thing right to date they
haven't spoken about this yet
they haven't seen the contract we see
the handshake
correct but we haven't seen the product
yet that's true correct as far as i'm
concerned anybody who's on ps now is
still playing on guy kai right and and
and not
it
there's been no announcement of that
transition happening right
i.e so we don't know if the quality is
going to be any better right
that's about that's fast it's going to
start any performance improvements
that's the thing right that's the thing
because if there is anybody noticed any
performance that's a good question
that's a good question
i i dipped my toe in
and the the and it was it was better
than on live
i'll say that
that was it okay that's where i'm at and
that's when i had and that's when i had
gigabit already oh wow so it was like
okay nah it's not there yet so my
question is what have they done to
improve upon that it's it's a hard
selling this way you look at it the day
and date is the sticking point the day
and date is what's gonna make you
because again xbox is giving you all of
that for 15 a month or ten dollars a
month
only counted to what i do i hear what
you're saying y'all correct my own
encounter is to me it's like until they
stop being profitable
they're going to continue to do that
like with the 70 games thing you know
i'm saying and i feel y'all i i we
listen let's just call it what it's not
superior whatever this is if that's what
it is it ain't spirit of game pass let's
just call it what it is we know that
right it's just
i'm curious if their base which is it
they almost have developed the nintendo
like
following in the sense that their base
don't really have a problem they still
going to play 70 games they based don't
have problem nintendo you know don't
discount game like to me the their
market they still know their market
enough that
it'll be interesting if their market
feels that that is value that's what's
interesting to me you know and we got to
see we got to see
mlb to show effect you know it's like
you think about it they already saying
okay mobius show is coming out and so on
and so forth so that's cool is this new
servers going to compete with that are
they going to be like we're going to
drop our new service we're going to play
him i'll be the show at the fourth
forefront i think that and that was yeah
yeah that marketing thing they could do
that was bonkers to me last year when
they when they see right that microsoft
puts it in game pass and you don't match
them that's insane to me that is insane
it's a good point that's because they'd
rather have that money like if they had
it's just an optics thing though like
but the thing is like if they had like a
huge subscription
amount of people then i think they would
have been a little bit more concerned
about it but they're not fighting a
subscription wars they're fighting
they're fighting platform cells they're
not fighting that right so putting that
in there i don't think it's going to
really help them sure that helps out
microsoft because it gives value to the
service but when you only have like
three million people on your service are
you really gonna to
get that kind of money away for let's be
real here like there's a lot of people
that like baseball but it's not the
majority right but it's one of those
things let's not let's not forget though
it will be the show even though it was
put on game pass was still one of the
top top selling games yeah yeah for sure
a period you know i mean on xbox at the
time so i mean i don't say just because
the game is just launching bringing date
on game passes i mean they they make
money i mean we all saw what they
pronounced they announced at gdc which
we're going to get to we don't get to
yet
but yeah
absolutely it's it's a good point
i agree everybody for the most part yeah
we got to see how this thing gonna hit
we gotta see what it is that's that's
just where it's at
soft let's get this that's what i'm
gonna combine last one because i know
we're going along and i got to combine a
lot of this stuff okay you want me to
read these super chat just read a couple
just got a couple okay um
oh jd gamer 10 super chat ps over there
playing twenty dollars a month for back
compatible demos
i'm losing my age twenty dollars for
backup patent demos you have got to be
kidding me i bet they think announcing
it with the new god of war demo makes it
a banger
jd gamer five dollars if we chat if the
rumors are true spartacus uh be be like
nothing to see over here just
playstation plus and ps now combined
game fast folks be eating good over here
that'd be interesting
yeah he go away
call this what it is nothing new we get
we got old arrogant sony back believing
that they control the industry and that
subscription services don't start until
they do it nonsense sony and get some
new servers wow
they don't have your name
exactly that we got hold on a second
one more from jd gamer 5 which every
time i hear traditional sony what that
really means is arrogance nobody wins
with that yeah right you feel how you
feel
know that exactly we'll combine this the
first one's kind of newspaper which is
king's top which is our marvel ultimate
coming to game pass um look like uh
pretty much that service in reference to
the digital comic subscription you get
all that latest perks for the uh you can
redeem it for three
free months available to game pass
ultimate members they can claim it
through the xbox perks galleries on the
xbox console and xbox app so um yeah
it's available to fans who are not
current or former subscribers of marvel
unlimited so that was cool you
definitely want to talk about that and
then i just want to kind of come back
there's a lot of stuff that happened
this week with gdc whether it was i
don't know if you guys caught the um
sarah bond and phil spencer interview
that was in representative talks there
we've got the um
from uh what's called the xbox gaming uh
cloud division with uh kim swift
that was announced as well you know we
had some id at xbox news so i'm gonna
approach a different let anyone focus on
what they want to talk about in
reference to this week with gdc and the
marvel let's start with um let's start
with delilah on this i'm curious with
there's a lot of stuff going on in tech
space so i want to know where your
head's at with gdc and tomorrow stuff
you can pick me first okay
so you know if you i mean pretty sure it
is you just mentioned they talked about
uh gdc and then also what how they're
doing uh they're adding the at the id at
azure servers
um so basically it's gonna help
developers who focus on um
i wanna kind of work this correctly but
like cloud-based components in their
game so name somebody cloud compute um
you get access just as you would id xbox
basically allow you to get services such
as support um
assistance analytics is as far as like
building your game and whatnot
that's human
for yeah for india because normally this
was a service that was only provided to
the publishers people that you know have
the capital to be able to make these
this level of investment but now it's
kind of opened up to it is in these in
any space um but
from what i got from like is what kim
swift is doing is a little bit different
um kim's swift it's not it's not like
she's you know have like a
gas you know
group or a game as a service group or
anything like that she's mostly going to
be managing um
that element basically
i'm trying to work this right but it's
more so managing um aspects of the cloud
like your lighting your physics
environments anything that needs extra
computation that's what her team is
going to be kind of helping bring to
fruition
um so she'll be over like directing all
of that yeah so yeah it's all it's all
parts of the same gotcha if you will but
it's not like a game pass type thing got
it right a cloud gaming type thing it's
more of a support kind of help
okay so it isn't you won't have
within her division you won't
necessarily have a team dedicated to
making cloud-based games right it's all
about right that's not that's not
exactly how
it was you know when i read everything
that they announced publicly that's not
real that's not what i got from it um
it's it's different in game pass that
the cloud you know is used to manage
aspects of the title such as like
lighting physics environments and extra
computation so
that's what she's going to be managing
not sure and then you bring that to
games owner it's pretty dope and lasting
deli um did also mention uh microsoft
announced azure game development virtual
machine which provides a remote work
workstation for game development and i
believe
uh sarah that was part of the idea that
azure um they talked about so basically
what is it what this is it helps
indie developers um use services like i
said that was normally available to
publishers so they'll get access to game
production game servers multiplayer um
things like that multiple multiplayer
servers
analytics ai anything to help with
getting their game which is cloud-based
um up to speed as opposed to relying on
okay i got to get signed by publisher in
order to help get servers for my cloud
game
they now have like more of a support
system from the microsoft end to get
those games out from like concept to
release so dope yeah i heard sarah
talking about i believe we're on a
podcast with benjamin nelson and the
push to see
them help independent developers in this
space is really cool and i've heard
something like azure credits and they
really seem to be working yeah so like
out the gate they get like 5 000 azure
credits you know which is which is a lot
you know especially if you ended you
don't got you can't afford to
let me set up my own form of servers
they also get access to playfab
make sure they turn them servers off
when they're done right i believe they
got turtle services
for the bill the bill going behind your
clay fab is basically the service issues
to like um for party you know for xbox
parties voice things like that
matchmaking that's what playfab is for
and also it they it's an output to it as
well so it shows like an analytics
system
um so they'll be able to either not only
get that all set up
contact be able to access support but
also be able to see the analytics
associated with all of that wow um it
also also provides code samples training
i mean it's a so full and commenting
type of thing that they're offering it's
very similar to id at xbox just on the
azure side everything wow very
impressive very impressive it's cool to
see them continue to advance in this
space and to make it i have to give them
credit this generation
what they've done for indies
has been phenomenal especially for where
they came from like with the um
i would say what they start at the birth
of the id at xbox program with um the
xbox one and just to see the advancement
there is pretty tremendous i wanted to
ask elle what what she thinks in
reference to this you know on the tech
side how excited are you about that
stuff and i forgot also if you had any
comments on the marvel thing before i
passed it off you how you felt about the
mobile marvel i think it's a i think
anytime you edit anything the game pass
i think it's a huge it's a huge look i
mean it's it's just adds to the value to
me
game pass already has a huge value
um i've never been big on just like
reading the comics online like that but
if it's free and it's accessible to me
i'm i'll try it out i like 3.99 3.99
that's right
that's right it's just an attitude here
we go go no doubt l boogie where we at
gdc anything stand out for you and the
marvel unlimited in game pass
uh as far as the marvel unlimited uh
like uh delilah said i'm not um big on
using it because i mean for me i didn't
want to have to pay for it so maybe now
that it's free
you know getting my toe in there i think
probably sharice is probably the most
excited out of the four of us to see
something like that happening but
yeah
but um
as far as the id at azure i think that
it's like a huge move i talked about it
on our show yesterday but they're almost
like
uh
opening up a market as well as creating
a brand loyalty within that market to
secure those folks for the long term
right yep because
they're basically saying hey all you
little folks that wouldn't have these
resources normally we're going to give
you those resources and add such we've
now built a rapport with you so now you
have all these people who are now
probably going to you know
put their games on xbox that may not
have done so before
so i don't know it's super smart it's a
platform agnostic of course right oh
yeah they are they did say in there that
they it doesn't matter if you're only um
providing for xbox you can be putting
your putting on any platform and they'll
still provide these services for you um
but still that builds that rapport right
yes um
now people who may have had uh
you know um
what do you want to say hesitancy
hesitancy with microsoft now those
barriers are gone right because now they
know that they don't have to only like
with id at xbox right you had to
um make games for xbox right
so now you're getting these services
without having those constraints so
you're going to have a lot of people
younger people right because they're at
gdc which is smart too
as you're coming into the business now
i've built this rapport with you so now
for years they're going to have this
revenue stream coming in
so
it's super smart yeah absolutely got
completely good great points l buggy
charisse gotta ask you
you know especially if i'm curious about
the marvel ultimate thing as well in the
text album where you at with that
first of all i am not the techie so
we're going to leave it we're going to
leave the gdc part out okay
got you got you good good team they
already know that's not me
i respect her she knows who she is
continue
but marvel unlimited
let's go
i already got it
um
like i said i am a comic book reader i
read almost a book a day and comic books
included
um my daughter reads so this is
something that saves some money because
books are expensive um
and if anything and now that game
gamepad subscribers can get them
um
hey the more the merrier like if you've
got any suggestions hop into our discord
we got you covered yeah um put the
discord in the chat
because
what's up girl
we got five minutes
i'm joking i'm joking it's nice because
it goes back like i can't can't remember
how far the catalog was back because it
goes like to the golden age
um yes
newer stuff that's like like six months
after it comes out in print it'll be
back on unlimited if i remember
correctly they might have to change it
but i usually read most of the older
stuff that i missed growing up because i
could not like really afford it
and then i still read some of the newer
stuff also but then when i have a
question and i have to go back and i can
pull it up real quick
and we saw how you do continue
[Laughter]
[Music]
all the interesting books that come
through the library
absolutely love love to see it lady
infamous where we at gdc 80 news stand
out to you and marvel unlimited
i'm gonna be honest with you marvel
unlimited
oh
i just didn't even
i got my disney plus i got my disney
plus oh you're good okay i'm good okay
i'm good with gdc okay
gdc is in san francisco my my home's my
home city so it's good to see the the
the moving and the grooving and the
people networking
at gdc the sarah bond spill spencer
interview is what got to me i
i love sarah bond yeah
i really do can we speak can i pause you
for what's that can we speak this into
existence that sarah barney needs to be
on grown women gaming at some point oh
yeah
okay we we got the pin tweet on the yeah
i've seen it i want to speak it into
existence because i i want y'all to get
it because we definitely like but i feel
like that has to happen with y'all first
right you know so so so come on sarah
get back
come talk to us we have a lot to say you
know what i'm saying let's grow a women
thing continue
i think with the growth of game pass i
think is really
really doing a significant like
position in gaming atmosphere as we
speak um it's not all about the full
price one-and-dones it's about what can
you do with your dollar how long can you
stretch it and how many games you can be
able to stretch the dollar and i think
with that interview
particularly in that subject i think
that's what hit me more and made me
appreciate the service of game pass
because with a year of it i don't ready
to play the game
already played a year's worth like work
so yeah pay for yourself and you get
extra extra games and you get perks so
um
i'm i'm glad to see gdc getting back in
the swing thing and hopefully we'll see
more sit downs and more fire chats and
yeah and i'm excited about that no doubt
no doubt
uh attic any news with marvel unlimited
or the gdc that caught your attention i
i like the fact that they're
uh supporting indies more because
i've noticed throughout the years like
the games that i really gravitate
towards are indies
and i feel like unless
the india like the people who really
innervate is indies and
triple a take those concepts and they
build on them
so you know if we have better indies
with more support and you know stuff
that
has always been out of their reach
because of finances and they have access
to it they can make better games that's
going to go up the uh the gaming tree i
like to say
double a's take that and then you know
we'll get a better gaming industry in
general uh down the line because of it
yeah no absolutely we love the seeing
them empowered and barry's eventually
being knocked down completely agree
solve marvel unlimited and gdc any
standouts for you
um so marvel unlimited again i i don't
read comics anymore like that and so
i agree with the value add i think any
time you just give me a value ad like i
i took the one month free of paramount
plus
to watch halos i did that uh so anytime
you give me a value add especially
something like like for three months it
really gives you the opportunity to see
the service and experience it and see if
you want to continue with it or not so
anytime you give me more for the same
amount of money i'm gonna be happy so i
may not engage with it but it is it's
definitely cool that it's there
um the gdc stuff unfortunately i did not
listen to uh the phil spencer sarah bond
interviewing yeah it was good yeah so i
have to i have to listen to that but in
terms of the other tech stuff that kind
of drew my eye
it was uh definitely talking about the
the idea at azure stuff because to me
again it just goes back to what i feel
microsoft's ultimate goal is is this
ubiquity of sort of the xbox name and
and and everything around xbox it's just
not this ecosystem of the console and
now the pc space it is sort of
everywhere you go in the gaming space
microsoft is there in some way shape or
form
and
by empowering when you when you think
about indie development and how much of
how much innovation happens in that
space and how
we get new people coming into the
industry through that space yes when you
tear down the barriers of being able to
engage with that where it doesn't have
to be on the console side it could be on
the pc side and you
you know and on the cloud side you can
just have access to these tools to build
your games on
um i just think they just keep doing
more and more stuff to become that place
where everyone sort of goes to for
development so it's it's to me it's just
another step in the direction of
the xbox and microsoft and that there's
a ubiquity there that they want to
achieve that i just think they keep
working towards so that's great i would
say it's similar to when we saw apple
put
apple products in the classrooms yeah
yeah so then those kids grow up yes
with apple products
then they buy apple and then and turn by
apple for their family you know so it's
that generational wealth yeah it's that
same notion you know they're bringing
these young developers in
they're giving them the resources them
in turn tell other folks
it is it's just happening without the
hardware right and that's right i mean
yeah we all remember a cog remember you
know apple is in the classroom playing
oregon trail oregon trail carmen san
diego
city yeah yeah
so you know yeah it's the same thing and
it is one of those things like you just
you're training people right it's a bad
way to think about it but it's true
you're training people to to sort of be
in your ecosystem all right
so i think that's great
on the tech side some of the stuff that
really uh caught my eye was it's funny
um
they were talking about the uh the
aspects of amd fidelity fx super
resolution 2.0 right
and what made me laugh about this is
that when we had jason ronald on right
yeah i'm always the one to ask jason ron
little questions i shouldn't be asking
yeah clearly
so when they announced super resolution
1.0
and obviously it's amd so i'm asking
them hey
looking to the future of what is
possible on on on the series consoles is
this something you're looking to
integrate he's like yeah i can't comment
on that right now
i remember that i remember when i was
like
yeah yeah i'm like yo you know i got i
gotta shoot the shots shut your shot you
said i just said
but uh you know when we look at these
consoles as powerful as they are right
they're still they're still not quite
punching up there with a with a high-end
high-spec pc but they're getting closer
and closer and to me a lot of these
things that happen in software that they
can help sort of allow these consoles
punch above their weight we're seeing
more more of it now trickle down so when
you talk about the the fidelity fx the
super resolution 2.0 what's exciting
about that is that it doesn't require
hardware today when you look at on the
pc side of fidelity fx games that
utilize it and it works well with you
can actually use it in conjunction with
g-force and dlss so both things work
together to again give you better
performance while while the the picture
you see on screen doesn't look degraded
necessarily in any real way so the fact
that this is finally now coming to
consoles and we probably won't see it in
games for years a couple of years to
come at least
it's just exciting to me that this is
finally being you know talked about
within the xbox sphere and we're going
to start seeing it
on the console side so that that to me
is is huge yeah
just because again like you know i i
don't i'm tired of talking about these
modes in games like oh the quality mode
we have you know
the performance mode because i've never
cared nothing about this one yeah i know
yeah but again if you're you know we at
this point we've played enough 60 fps
stuff if you're primarily a
console gamer and you've transitioned
over to these new consoles the vast
majority of stuff you're going to be
able to play at 60 fps in some mode or
another right right the smoothness of 60
fps cannot be denied and it's hard to go
back even physically like playing
something at 30 fps after you playing a
lot of stuff at 60 immediate it just
looks choppy like you have to get
readjusted to it even looking smooth at
30 even if it is a lock 30.
so
it's just one of those things that it's
gonna help that transition to hey the
baseline is 60 for everything right
and it's just again it's exciting to to
see these consoles evolve in a way that
past consoles just couldn't do they
weren't capable of doing right and the
the machine that we're gonna get at at
the end of the generation you know
whatever
five six seven years down the line is
going to look different than the machine
we got day one in our house so that
that's very interesting to me and i'm
happy to see that that was really the
big stuff out of gdc that um
that i kind of like you know i was
excited to see yeah um
and just i'm just glad that it's
happening again you know that's kind of
the tip of the spear for
the beginnings of going back to
in-person events i know later in april
we're going back to we're going back to
pax and you know getting ready for that
so i'm excited to see the willingness to
go back to the stuff and kind of get
back that sense of normalcy that we lost
i'll add that on as my final thing yeah
that that part was refreshing you know
to see yeah developers together conor
again obviously because of the pandemic
we've been robbed of a lot of stuff so
to see the in-person stuff on some
levels cool shout out to all any
information yeah the the sarah bond and
phil spencer it really hit me and i just
i'd be honest like i like the direction
sarah is going it it feels from the
outside looking in that she could be
potentially groomed to be something even
greater at the company and um i just
like what they would talk about just
empowering creators empowering
developers i feel like you know we get
it you know everyone loves the big
splashy headline like in sports i look
at it like yo microsoft sign you know
whatever like it's the big free agent
acquisition with the activisions and all
that but to me i like working at the
farm right on the farm level the new
talent the id at xbox stuff all those
empowering them because like the lala
everyone was saying is that
you know when you and l book excuse me
was saying in reference to like once you
get them i don't say like indoctrinated
like it's literally once you get in your
system you once you borrow yeah and
they're using these amazing tools and
you're like yo this is great you know
and then now it sets a culture and then
you set off like a future generation of
talent you know almost looking at soft
like almost like the farm system in
baseball in a sense right like you you
really you create a loyalty thing yes
you start to cultivate it i was one of
those you know i mean you one of them
apple 2e kids you know
from young in the classroom that was
like a big thing back then but from a
game development standpoint i think it's
dope marvel unlimited obviously i'm all
fanboy any feature is really cool to me
so i like that as far as having that the
law on deck so to speak i would hope
they put an app though just for me being
lazy they have to go outside but yeah
you know it is what it is it's a cool
service but other than that yeah i i
think the azure stuff is really cool
they're forward thinking you know
multi-platform all that stuff just
giving devs the tools they need to knock
down the cost of entry is huge and then
you start to see the future devs of the
world start to use that tech and create
great stuff so i'm excited about that
the geek and techie in me love that type
of stuff so yeah we'll see what's going
on and last thing phil did say okay
and i'll go ahead and you go ahead you
finish that no i'm gonna say and phil
the thing cool thing that i think that
phil said that i think people reiterate
is a lot of people have this
misconception that i think that
in order for microsoft to be successful
getting passed in the subscription model
is the only way and what i like that he
said he keeps preaching the diversity of
the business model and and saying that
you know hey if there's people who are
only going to do retail that are not
going to do the subscription service
like basically like they're not
predicate success not predicated solely
on the game pass model and i thought
that was very interesting that he
reiterated that again i think the second
time he said it so look they want you in
they just however you get in you know
whether it be you know retail cloud
whatever they want you in and they're
cool where you're at so i thought that
was interesting but that's all i got so
i'm just gonna say something forget
about it yeah the last thing i i forgot
to mention um was uh yeah the psvr ii
was reportedly sort of uh shown to devs
over at gdc
and they were pretty excited about it so
um
yeah exactly i want to see what it is
that this thing can do
if it sort of does step it up over what
a lot of you know a lot of people have
uh you know the meta quest two and they
have you know i wanna see what the step
up is and uh it's good to hear that devs
are are liking what they see no it's
good and it's good overall for the band
i know you know on the matter side they
they're actually excited about so they
get there because it builds the space so
to speak right so more people in space
more people get comfortable with it so
we will see but um that's what i got you
know can do this uh poll you're gonna
get the i get the poll and then you get
the super chats or
yeah go ahead and pull all right
all right new iop poll adequate like
this with the recent release of the
paramount halo tv series
did xbox rob the fan base of an epic
master chief face reveal fix your face
delilah within the actual caleb j
franchise
the choices are a yes show runners did
not respect the law and importance of
master chief with humanization and an
unearned face reveal
b
no this is a unique halo story that is
non-canon pyramid has the right to use
their own interpretation of the master
chief or c i don't care if 343 put in a
maskless pablo schreiber and halo
infinite battle pass we gon revolt those
are the choices please ride when it goes
up
on twitter salute and put your hands
together rocked with us for the whole
marathon
grown women
the lady for the realm
super salute to y'all you know i just
love the consistency
i love like i said the fact that you've
been doing what you're doing it's an
excellent show please if y'all have not
already subscribe to the damn channel
we're gonna put the links in there
they've really been putting it down for
a long time and not just on like i said
gaming topics they've really been
getting developers they you know once
the pandemic stuff they've been on the
floor they've been at the show they've
gone they've done the work and that's
the thing you like to see it i always
want to salute their blessings so let's
get the shout outs going on and start
with lady the og my [ __ ] gang bang bang
all day where can the five people find
you what you got going on sis oh you
guys already know is the best thing on a
saturday morning growing will be gaming
9am 12 noon eastern every saturday
sometimes we got guests sometimes we
don't
know it's okay but we will be there uh
one of the most consistent podcasts in
the last few years
i need people to remember that and put
respect on that
um also i do twitch uh twitch
dot tv because we had a
it was a mistake yesterday we twitched
our tv
yeah cause we was doing this yesterday
dot tv
slash lady infamous under lady
underscore infamous four one five okay
um we're gonna beat elder ring today
we're gonna do guardians of the galaxy
tomorrow and we got some things that
we're going to do on deck and thank you
so much for us
for joining today and thank you for
inviting us and thank you for the chat
for being awesome and shout out to the
haters because we see y'all there too
they listen do they pay their that means
y'all blowing up when y'all got the
consistent haters that means y'all
blowing up we like that
no duh let's shoot my says l
bugs what's going on elbow where can i
find people find you what you got going
on with yourself
yeah so you can find me every saturday
on gwg you can also find me on twitter
talking my nonsense
and
um
yeah yeah i know we love you because
it's like past food yes
[Music]
i was waiting for the message like cog
y'all know we got it we're leaving yeah
yeah
i appreciate it prepared i appreciate
you
we watch y'all so we know
what's on the menu today al because
sometimes some of those menus are you
running up there just like you need to
join our discord because then you get
all my photos oh my gosh yeah
set that up
sunday menus
right yeah i am i'm trying to be more
healthy so you will see more healthy
stuff there but uh
i try to add a
lot of different you know food i don't
make the same same type of stuff all the
time
absolutely yeah you can find me there
thank you all for listening we
appreciate y'all make sure you head over
to gwg yes uh follow our youtube um i
will let you know that we um
we allow some nonsense
that's so fun sometimes
no i mean we have fun all the time we
have fun all the time but you know if
you go two left you know you get blocked
got to get your body here
just watch your mouth when you're in
there don't be disrespectful that's all
you know all right cool
lady charisse best librarian in the game
home girl best writer what's going on
with you making the five people find you
um mr groceries here again thank y'all
to the lords letting us come and hang
with y'all today um i skipped church for
this oh
[Music]
but again thank you all for coming your
chat has been nice hanging with y'all
have been awesome shout out to my ladies
for always coming through with that
knowledge in that
beautifulness that is us um but yes it's
your groceries here you can always find
me hanging around and lurking in
somebody's chat
um
i'm on twitter in somebody's feed
reminding being nosy i am
on twitch in the morning streaming um
early morning streams because that's
before i go to work so if you're
um it's on super early
drinking your coffee come hang with me
on twitch and we'll you know play some
destiny i think next week we'll jump on
tunic okay um so you know just you know
thank y'all for coming remember you know
like we said on our show remember to
wash your hands yes
wash your behinds
[Music]
hand sanitizer and lifestyle is my best
friend
for sure i i know what that's that was
strong librarian energy that was public
yeah you know i feel that
i'm at the behind part but you do have
to remind people yeah some people do
that too yes for sure no doubt and of
course
no doubt my homie super proud of her
yeah delilah hd you know i want to give
you your roses because you know it's
always cool i remember seeing you in the
chat used to be lurking and i didn't
know you were at the time and just to
see you in the development and your
journey you know what you got going on
right now is super inspiring and we need
to see more of it so i want to give you
that and then also what you got going on
with yourself and grow women what's up
with you oh man um
well gwg of course you know you all know
you can i'll be there with the ladies on
saturdays
um but you can also follow me on twitter
delilah underscore hd or we have an
announcement to make it within the next
six months
something i'm doing on the side
no doubt no thank you thank you for
inviting us man it was a great show and
uh dabbled around a little long but like
yes like they said we understand you
know it is food o'clock right we knew
the assignment
i'm pretty sure
i appreciate y'all we always give people
the option to say hey
we got a time limit straight
we're out of pocket right now but for
sure absolute salute and again everybody
please again support show some love you
know it's just good gaming topics
passion for gaming and that's what we're
about you know we want to put the light
on people that i feel deserve it and i i
feel you guys should be way bigger than
what you are and um
it's cool to see the growth still so
salute be out there on a journey solve
we got the super chat in respect for the
ladies
if they have to go it is okay we got a
super chat but if you're not we kicking
nobody out but um if you want you ain't
got to kick me out but i'm going to go
at this stage
don't say that because you know how to
go and then they ask questions and then
you know
anybody else just let me let us know we
gotta do our business but um yeah um
real quick um attic before we we can do
our drink right or we're gonna do the
super chats now
i don't know let's just do our outros
and then we're going to go
attic we're going to find people find
you thank you for helping me get my
chain back in the ring what's going on
mm-hmm find me on twitter
iop i want to thank the guests for
coming on i actually have been pushing
for you guys to come back yeah this is
alex this is alex
it was uh
even though we frustrated you yeah yeah
yeah
hey little time if he was not he was not
happy about inviting y'all in
first
[Laughter]
yeah i appreciate we're coming through
uh keep in mind we're going to be doing
the uh community day uh with uh with the
lords uh yes
we're kind of stuck between wwe and uh i
think it was among us or
one of those two we might split it up
and do an hour of both i don't know
but it's cool you can't you can't do an
hour just the wwe you can't yeah
because that's a full day watch watch me
he tried to get out of that it's cool we
started we started at one start at two
and i'm like okay let's move on
[Laughter]
made me play games that was that was
originated before i was born that was
like five of them but year one
that is true i appreciate ever coming
through uh you know uh you know we
definitely
yeah you guys came through pretty uh
pretty strong today yeah king
unfortunately couldn't stay for the uh
for the foolishness uh yeah he was ready
for the smoke i know uh and i'm sure
next week's gonna be
glorious for king if you know what's
funny
next week's gonna be you're gonna see
king real strong
or king go gonna be like you know what
you got to give it to sony you know they
they did something right for once yeah
it's going to be interesting i'm pretty
sure it's going to be the latter next
week i think i think king going to be
messy because i don't think they're
going to do anything next week he's
going to be messy regardless it could be
the best thing on planet yeah he'll find
him you're gonna be messing he'll find
something
sometimes
sometimes he surprises you
i have to say you know uh from the last
time i was on uh king has gotten a
little more showtime yes oh yes with the
outfits and everything
i see
what it is
because there's you know social media
likes to do space right right right they
like to talk about the cakes okay
he wants to give
[Applause]
[Music]
you can find me not playing any games
you know you know how that goes but
i mean later this week i will be on and
they'll be the show yeah i know you'll
find time to do that
listen y'all be dominant i'm feeling
[ __ ] one time we got a semi-solid t baby
baby yeah you see we picked the old boy
from atlanta
dodge is looking strong all the time i
don't know
yeah my yanks are looking a little
suspect we'll see let's see what happens
um yeah but ladies i mean i had the
pleasure of meeting you guys what couple
years back at e3 um and you every single
week you guys do the work to to to make
the
the stigma that that some neanderthals
in our um
in our community think that you know you
know girls that don't belong or whatever
the case may be every single day you
guys do the work to to show that
you guys are something else especially
with the tag expertise like you know you
saw a chat play you know playfully
digging at you guys or whatever trying
to get you guys but
you guys do amazing things um just just
keep doing it and like cox said that for
me you guys need to be so much bigger
and
you know hopefully you know you guys
have the patreon going now and doing
different stuff and just getting the
name out there more and more it's going
to continue to happen and grow because
you guys are great absolutely amazing i
appreciate that i know absolutely
absolutely ladies of the realm let's get
to the business
that's it
let's see what we got here we got uh
cedric h five dollars we chat these
spartacus tears sounded like only fans
tears yeah wow
that's ridiculous look
i know we're gonna skip super chats for
a second since it was a shorter show can
we get everyone's
i tried to warn them the warning ladies
and gentlemen they're about to get
ridiculous in a minute right jd gave
them five dollars one more time for
those that didn't hear traditional sony
is code for arrogant sony and nobody
wants that i better not hear nobody
capping for demos yeah it's gonna be a
conversation
and we got splendiferous two dollar
super chat saab there's the same for
people who like to put toes in i don't
want to know what that's saying just
keep that keep that to yourself thank
you very much
and we got donald taco five dollars for
chat i feel like with ue5 and id at xbox
the gap between indies and double a or
sometimes even aaa will be the smallest
ever this generation yeah i do think the
tools available to everyone kind of it's
amazing what what what we've seen from
you know single people making games and
whatnot so yeah that that space is is a
lot more blurred than it's ever been
and we got gamer by choice 20 super chat
thank you iop for introducing me to to
the grown woman gaming this is a fire
show i just subbed and youtube groups
should do more shows together this was
amazing yes this is what gaming is all
about that is absolutely absolutely
getting back to it that's what we're
doing
problem with youtube groups is you you
guys say our podcast is long now imagine
oh yeah all right oh yeah
i had to speed run some topics at the
end so that let you know right yeah
then we got tony bryant 10 super chat
fantastic show from layaway weapons to
banana hammocks physics
that topic was lit
also called it please don't tell me
they're going to have chief outside of
his suit
no comments i don't think they're gonna
go that far but yeah no i don't think
we're gonna see him as soon
you know no
i would not
let oh brother jesus
let me play with your joystick oh he
back snagging back
i want to hear soft talk about the
nintendo game about sucking stuff wow i
would buy a switch for that saab can we
play co-op no we cannot play i don't
want to play go out with usoff
listen you might have to put that in the
patreon tip
but on what time with song
i feel like that has to go on another
website
what's up with the likes people get the
likes up pick up your gwg we'll check it
out thank you so much appreciate it
then we got ham solo gaming two dollar
super chat absolutely she brought the
gospel old great show y'all thank you
they didn't [ __ ] man
we got a couple ones that jumped in at
the end we got suicide kings two dollars
super chat sent this just because there
were only ten gay girl women gaming ftw
all right
that's right put the channel in the
description i'll go get that
then we got necromancer zell 5 super
chat since it was a shorter show can we
get everyone's top 100 video games of
all time that's funny
that we got don otaku five dollars of a
chat you should be proud that we will
pay y'all to keep going for as long as
possible we love y'all inp and dwg we're
also a great guest yeah
listen we're pretty we say that we love
it but you know we hungry out here
we do gotta eat it and we do gotta
listen
hunger
[Laughter]
[ __ ] i need that stuff man that bro i
got that sour for you bro i got that
sour right now go to advancedgg.com and
put in that cool iron lord or the
checkout y'all know what to do damn hit
you right to get that new one get that
oh we got the split gate tool we got the
split gate if you like split game
remember ball pops from back in the day
we got the bomb pop son
yeah we got that rocket pop split gate
go get that cold iron lord on the
checkout put this in the description
powder there we go split difference two
dollar super chat yeah i seen him on
twitter too with that powder 1k
powder let's listen man i got y'all bro
wow i gotcha i got i got it
with the way they're talking yeah no
that's what we've been saying online you
gotta watch the way you say things i got
that i got that advance for you i got
that advance for you go come come get
that
yeah we're good we caught up all right
cool
i'm not gonna say nothing else
i'm leaving that alone
listen i'm just both anyway look
fantastic show everybody much love we
told y'all get over to gwg they are one
of the premier gaming podcasts the
homies always good to see them in the
realm fantastic show anybody got
anything else or we're going to let
y'all enjoy yes one more from donald
trump
when we getting lunch with the lords
lunch when you're paying attention
what are you paying yo
no no don't don't say that cause
somebody cause they will get it
they will literally do that so look yo
he said lord cog move away i'm stupid
anyway let everybody enjoy your sunday
we are out peace
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
foreign